two we are back my friends it is Friday
April 28th we just had a little bit of a
oopsy-doopsy we started the podcast and
there was no audio
so we erased it
and our broadcasting again
holy can y'all hear me this time
let's get some whales in the chat if you
can hear me whale
[Applause]
everybody say wayo we getting whales in
the chat whale yep yep yep yeah so uh we
do have a great show people are asking
why we did it
for non-live viewers The Experience
would be very very very bad if the first
like five minutes was just no audio and
really hard crackling
so
I do this for the greater good
anyway welcome everybody
um Ela is not here today because today
is a well it's a big day for us
she is
going to the doctor this afternoon
you get that Perfect rated
aa4 egg
female
hey I wasn't hey
hold on
a A4 egg female perfect grade fertilized
pasture-raised grass-fed no hormones and
that's not true she's on a lot of
hormones Brown shell or white shell
it's spotted
[Music]
uh as she's being she's hopefully gonna
be getting pregnant this afternoon with
our future baby daughter
how about Dad huh that's amazing isn't
it
so uh next Friday we'll know for sure
um if it sticks is she gonna call in
later at when the procedure is done so
we'll hear from you in a little bit but
yeah that's pretty exciting man
I can't believe we're doing it you guys
two little two kids is crazy
three is gonna be
that's gotta be a circle of hell
it's not super deep but it's one of them
maybe two or three two or three
um also I'm happy to announce that you
guys remember how I got the fika fish
rash it's happening again
I don't know I had to put a ton of
Vaseline on my face this morning I don't
know how shiny I am
I felt it coming around my eyes a few
days ago so I started putting it on my
eyes the ointment I got from the
dermatologist and I think it's good
there but now it's coming all here I had
to get out of bed last night at like
in the middle of the night and shaved
because it was just it was so so nasty
and itchy I couldn't stop and I hate to
tell this to you guys because uh it is a
little gross but it's on my balls and
dick oh damn am I really and it's so
itchy you guys I and I told I told the
dermatologist but she did she didn't
explain she's she's just kind of like an
allergy but not really just put this on
it I'm like I don't know what's causing
it are you being poisoned like Andrew
Tate
I may be being poisoned you guys
poisoning me they want me itchy
I won't stay itchy
um
Gabe I thought you weren't gonna call in
today how are you
good we just had an emergency I have to
check our nephew um sentina to the
Urgent Care because he has a stomach
ache I'm in the car right now
is he okay
he seems to develop we're at the store
we're waiting at the start to get some
stuff for the baby
oh there's a baby what's the baby
Santino
wait oh the knee as you're talking about
the baby wasn't feeling well
yeah the baby stuff oh that's that's
horrible how old
the baby is like three years old okay is
it that well that's not a baby Gabe
that's like a toddler that's like a
toddler that's like a child
[Music]
no we don't we don't we we do it we do a
um more suppressed more kind of somber
woo today because the baby's not feeling
wait is that is that him or her yeah
that's not a baby that's not a baby
that's like a fully grown human being
foreign
what are we gonna get Santino oh he's
not having it he's not loving it I'm
glad you're feeling better today
wish him wish him well we wish you well
Santino no he says no I don't think yeah
yeah you didn't seem that interested uh
yes he has a Spider-Man too
what are we getting them from the store
to make him feel better
some pediatric life you know that oh
yeah
Pedialyte
Pedialyte yeah yeah I'll move Pedialyte
[__] baby Pedialyte
baby love me some Pedialyte there's some
pedial light baby hey do you ever um do
you ever take Pedialyte for a hangover
game I heard that's good
um I never heard of it but it's a good
idea okay maybe it will help yeah it's
an idea yeah it could
some people say it does
and did you do the trick did you take
your um
I'm sorry that's your nephew right or is
it your niece my nephew yeah your niece
sorry I can't see back there very well
um did you take your nephew just you
take him to the Urgent Care
it's me and um my cousin he's the one um
taking care of the baby
is he there next to you
no he's at the store oh okay he's in
there buying stuff okay
well Gabe listen I hope your nephew's
feeling better nobody likes to see uh
sick kids you know what I mean
I especially it ruins the weekend right
weekend's supposed to be fun baby
[__] yeah [__] baby but it's not his
fault right it's not his fault it's just
sad yeah it's nature nature Nature's
fault
[__] nature it's not your fault okay
[__] [__] nature do you have a problem
saying [__] in front of your nephew or
no no I was better
right
they'll learn that word right right
[__] baby
[__] in my dick pull and put it in with
a cocktail mixer [__]
foreign sometimes I surprise myself yeah
you have to pee out the sickness and put
it in your brains whoa
all right Gabe listen you you take care
of your nephew okay but I'm glad you're
being a good uncle out there
who the [__] is Uncle Gabe he's a good
ass Uncle that's who all right yeah
um Who's the goodest Uncle Gabe who the
good is Uncle Gabe who though yeah
that's good it's Uncle Gabe who's the
goodest Uncle Gable yeah
all right Gabe take care all right have
a good weekend we'll we'll meet you uh
next next uh Friday all right Friday
baby it's Friday baby it's the weekend
baby
it's the weekend baby
[Applause]
[Music]
damn good air
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
laughs
oh my God
he broke
I'm just laughing for nothing
all right we you know it's an
exploration you never know where it's
gonna go but I'll get I you could always
count on one thing I am willing to
derail this show to win every time oh
yeah all right Gabe take care we love
you okay
[Applause]
[__] that is the kind of quality
content that people tune in every week
for that's right
yeah so um
big news oh boy
and the uh we had a mega episode about
Crowder on Wednesday
um because he got divorced which uh
you know your fault it's his fault he's
a giant piece of [__] he's a racist
bigot homophobe who will not shut up
about family values about being a good
Christian judging other people's
marriages and relationships
and so he got divorced and that was
great or that was a great irony
that we all enjoyed yeah
but now what came out yesterday
is actually
quite
remarkable actually and disturbing I
would even say yes sir
so um this reporter uh
his name's I don't I don't recall his
name exactly off the top of my head but
he got in possession a three-minute ring
footage from Crowder's backyard
where he is verbally abusing his
eight-month
pregnant with twins wife
and a ton of other real uh rev yashar
Ali is his name and a whole bunch of
other Revelations that I will get into
but it's it's juicy
in the fact that I think Stephen Crowder
is a disgusting human being
it's obviously I'm so sad for his wife
and his kids but I'm sure it's better
for them to be away from me he is a
Monster yeah I mean he this man is a
monster and I and I can only psychopath
and I can only hope that this will
irreparable irreparably damage his
career
one can only hope because it will in
this climate I've already seen it I mean
a lot of his uh
a lot of his Sims are
um think that that is uh totally normal
and how you should talk to your wife so
obviously they won't be turned by this
but I've seen a lot that are like holy
[__] this guy is so many self-reports by
the way including the quartering who's
like what this is just a normal marital
uh conversation I was like quartering
wife whoever you are run bro I was
riding so hard for Jeremy I take it all
back take it back all of it back I'm so
ashamed we warned you I know I know it's
my fault take it back the quartering is
a little IQ inbred loser and you know
what retweet I'll say it again we hate
you now I must defend Ethan Klein it is
one of the most difficult things I have
to do yes well uh
sorry to put you in that position buddy
but so we're going to get into all that
and it is a whole juicy thing I just
want to do some top of the show stuff
before we jump into the meat of it we
also have a an Olivia PowerPoint Sydney
Sweeney Glenn Powell drama I've been
seeing a lot of this on my timeline I
haven't delved into it obviously I know
who Sydney Sweeney is well you know what
I got you on that front I explain all of
it we'll take you through everything
okay I got it I got it I got it so lots
of fun stuff here plant
um
there is no ads today so I encourage
everybody to consider becoming a member
fantastic perks including a members only
live stream every Tuesday there's a new
BTS going up on Monday
access to Discord participate in chats
and polls you can tell me during a live
show that uh you did not pay five
dollars to watch me do whatever I'm
doing right and that is a privilege if
you become a member you actually become
a co-producer of the show and can direct
it from the livestream right it's a nice
benefit you're you're essentially own a
piece of the show yes so so that's a
valuable uh perk
but yeah thank you guys to all of our
members who support the show thank you
to all of our honest members anyway uh
maybe 11 miles so much
yeah uh c-man also a friend of the show
Matt might be calling in we don't really
know what's going on with c-man
c-man is of course our resident foot
fetishist people like semen he's the
greatest man I like c-man I can't get
enough C man he's a genuinely uh
audience favorite yeah no it might be
the most authentic person alive
so so he reached out to Dan just out of
the blue and said hey I want to call
into the show yeah he he emailed me uh
let me take a look I actually have my
thread with him open over here he
emailed me
um
it was yesterday he emailed me yesterday
at 4am 4am he said let me know when I
can come back on the show thanks
and I said you for sure open door policy
for cement yeah I mean that's obviously
not a problem we love having him so I
said hey good to hear from you
um happy to have you are you available
tomorrow which is today uh and then told
him the time and he told me can't
tomorrow
I need to after 5 PM Eastern
which is in 30 minutes from or no yeah
30 minutes from now well it's like I
mean that that is not like a
grammatically correct sentence I need to
after 5 PM Eastern
is in response to that so I'm not
basically I don't know what he was
trying to say so I'm just gonna send him
the zoom link and we're just gonna hope
for the best he might call in well he
said he said no I can't today but then
he said I can only do it after 5 p.m
Eastern which is when we do our show
right that was what was so confusing
yeah so we sent him the link so we might
be uh hearing from c-man so that'll be a
joy
uh here's some recent c-man posts uh how
was Portland today he asked
how was Salt Lake removed oh no uh he
said how was Salt Lake City he asked
I remember it being so beautiful with
mountains in the background he said on
the Salt Lake City out there
he wants to have conversations but here
we are c-man
there's thousands of people here wanting
to converse with you
he is the most elusive friend of the
show and the hardest to get he comes
down once a year he only comes when he
wants to we we don't control C man he
goes dark we're his guests yeah you
cannot request
from him yeah no you can't be like hey
let's do a segment on this date no you
won't hear from 37 feet that's the
termin he asked how's Florida doing I
love Florida need the sunshine he says
in our Florida
how's Arizona just checking in he says
Arizona has some great looking cactuses
so anyone here from Arizona that's a
good conversation starter sure
is Phoenix pricey on rents is that okay
I don't think he would be moved to
Phoenix he's a New Yorker all the way
well maybe he was thinking about it
maybe I think he's dispensive so I think
he's just wanting to have a conversation
about rent prices in Phoenix I don't
think he'd move there
uh the scenery in Colorado is so
beautiful Oregon is pretty in the summer
these are all just General posts to the
city subreddits here's Idaho Idaho
looked like a beautiful place but I
heard it's getting expensive
yeah uh there's a lot of these man he's
he's really reaching out to a lot of
Metro
metropolitan areas
so he's been busy well if you recall he
films his foot wrestling videos in
Florida right he's looking to explore
business
across the whole nation
a seismo said been a while since
Sebastian Epp but I wanted to hit my
Milestone before super chatting I'm down
50 pounds in about 2.5 months wait what
how's that that's a lot I'm inspired by
you Ethan not the Jim Bros that's what
the [__] is up love y'all and in case
you hadn't heard Zach Lewis live at the
Roxy May 13th
thank you very much appreciate that wait
50 pounds in two and a half months
that's like insane that's crazy
well how do you even do that does that
mean you're just you might be a big boy
a big boy yeah I guess if you're really
big you can lose a lot of weight good
for you man keep it going we love it I
just want to be left alone
I know
um let's see Jerry Springer
I don't know if some of y'all are too
young but Jerry Springer was
honestly a cultural icon in my childhood
and my teenage years it was inescapable
this man was on every channel of basic
cable I don't care what channel it was
Jerry someone was fighting on Jerry
Springer those those you know boxing
Rings were going off
right right I forgot they did that you
know that show was so [__] sleazy
it's like the sleaziest show ever yeah I
mean I saw I watched a clip of it since
he passed away I was watching some and I
was quite shocked by just how [__] up
it is he bought uh depraved it is I mean
it is it is really and Jerry by all
counts seems like a like
he would go on it there and you know he
ended each episode with Jerry's thoughts
which was just really thoughtful sweet
uh insightful and it was just it's like
what are you there wasn't his like sign
off always like be good to each other
yeah like he just had tried to like make
it into this wholesome thing when he had
just hosted a show with you know people
ripping each other's hair out for 20
minutes and then
later in his life he became Judge Jerry
I don't know if you know that I did not
know that he had a he had a pretty
prolific career as uh one of these
daytime judges huh Judge Jerry did not
know that and he was a mayor before that
he was mayor or he ran
mayor of Cincinnati yeah he stepped down
when did that happen I think it was
before the show yeah he was disgraced
yeah it was before he was a disgraced
right wait what did he do he got caught
with a prostitute oh that seat but you
know why you got it you already got
caught I heard this on the radio driving
home he got caught because he was
writing checks to them that's awesome
wait was he doing write-offs
as a masseuse it's a masseuse
Jerry but you know at least he lives
that life he's not a poser this Vandal
true he's the real deal uh there were so
many crazy Jerry Springer moments
you know I remember when he brought
someone from the KKK
and uh to fight a bunch of black I mean
uh some black people came on it was
[__] nuts
here's like KKK people in a Nazi and uh
they got in a fight
shocking
I mean look at this I mean you know this
narcotic and as he was a Trailblazer
though I mean this man yeah oh yeah
is also on the Austin Powers movie
he had uh Dr Evil and his son come on
and they fought I think there was a clan
member in that one yeah it was that's
right I thought this was from them at
first
I'm sure he made a vast Fortune from
from this show it was so highly uh
it was a it was a cultural Force I mean
people chanting Jerry like anytime
anybody got into any sort of fight in
the 90s you could count on a crowd of
people around them starting to just
chant right this was years before world
star was being yelled yeah yeah it was
the original like shouting world star
yeah yeah
that's crazy that's true I think they
they still air it on like uh you know
local broadcast station hell yeah yeah
reruns yeah the newest upload was like
two days ago wow yeah [__] Legend
still entertaining path to the Crave
here's a little uh tribute born during
the war the sad part of the story is
that most of my family was exterminated
in Nazi concentration camps so okay
Legend
tap dance on the graves of Nazis out
here
by
bringing them on the show and live
minorities
we lost our family mom and dad did
survived two weeks before it goes into
Poland to start World War II which was
September I didn't know all that that's
pretty crazy but enough about Jerry
Springer resting that's the best part of
that video I did yeah
okay
you gotta keep going it was just seemed
you guys hear he said Dad
instead of that who said that
Jerry or full screen full screen it too
the first of 1939. mom and dad got the
88s and 89th last visas which permitted
Jews out of
um Germany and they got to England where
a month later my sister was born and
then also during the War I was born when
I'm five dad buys four tickets on the
Queen Mary and we sailed to New York
Arab world news paying homage to the
great Jerry Springer who better to
eulogize him than that
rest in peace
died peacefully Saturday at his home
clearly a loss after a brief illness oh
I remember he used to do like too hot
for TV ones too where they people would
have their clothes ripped off and so
they made like a whole compilation of
that and then they sold it on VHF oh my
God
that's so lazy so awesome how much of it
do you guys think was fake I know people
still debate it I think a lot of it was
but you know there was definitely
realness there it's a hybrid I think
yeah yeah exactly in that interview that
Arab world news is showing he also he
there was like accusations a couple
years ago that they faked the whole
thing Jerry's like oh it was like 98
real see I believe Jerry and here's the
reason why I've always thought it's
mostly real
is that you can't who are these people
they're they're not actors these are
like normal ass people right it would
advertise call this number yeah be
Jerry's help I mean like well I don't
think that they were ever actors but I
think that like the fights and stuff
were probably like but they're really
fun trying to [__] these people are
trying to hurt each other right you can
tell that fight's real yeah and I always
said like either way fake or not like
how big was that paycheck that they were
doing this wild ass [__] nothing like
probably next to nothing but I think
they just flew them out put them in a
hotel yeah I doubt they even paid them
oh and then I remember people would run
when people were crying because like
they found out their significant other
cheated on them with like a klansman
it's always like it's not just they
cheated it's like they cheated on you
with like a
at the time it was always like a trans
person that was like the shock there was
a lot of like trans exploitative yeah it
was it was pretty exploitative thinking
back at the time but it was like my
boyfriend cheated on me a lot of
exploiting uh like uh unhoused people
too I remember oh did they have homeless
people yeah okay
love that for him
yeah no it's it's this schlocky ass
reality television so there he is uh oh
you know what this isn't and I'm such an
idiot man I was like why is it so low
quality
of course arable news would have this
uploaded in 4k yeah my man
2160p my friend
for this re-uploaded uh standard
definition television footage from the
90s that is not 4K sucks is in
everything he tried where's that
everyone's saying Hannah uh had an
appearance no I'm seeing a lot of people
in the chat mentioning what I gotta look
that up yeah
I've long friend and this box man for
the family and a statement on social
media a rest in peace Jerry Springer
you're hearing boxing bells in heaven
I'm sure are people maybe confusing it
for Maury yeah I see that she's on Mori
to be honest I actually think more is
even bigger of a scumbag than uh Jerry
Springer Maury rev he's the one that
created or popularized at least the
whole paternity test thing which was so
[__] up
right the you are not the father with
yeah it's so [__] yeah at least Jerry
was uh you know you you knew what you
were signing up for with the Jerry
Springer Show yeah you didn't have a
veneer well I guess he did do like you
said the cool thing where he like tried
to spin it into a positive message it
was almost like a joke to be honest yeah
I don't think Jerry ever pretended to be
a good guy
where Mori was always trying to be like
I'm the good guy and I'm not trying to
help you find the truth like shut the
[__] up Mori douche as a monster okay
she was on Memorial but they are pretty
much interchangeable you guys don't have
that wrong
uh so uh but the title of the most uh
psychotic show host goes to set was it
Sally Jesse Raphael who brought out a
man
he brought she I think it was her she
brought
a dude on her show under the premise
that there was a secret crush the secret
crush was his best friend who was coming
out as gay
um he went home that next day and
murdered his uh oh he murdered the guy
who remembered that story the gay dude
for saying he was in love with him it's
quite quite quite nasty stuff
so that was Sally Jesse was that her
well
I'm looking at her Wikipedia Jenny Jones
yeah yeah okay yeah yeah apologies to
Sally Jesse Raphael whoever that is no
the she also had uh like a tabloid show
like Jerry Springer but uh you were on
the right track but Sally Jones
Jenny Jones Jenny Jones has the uh
exclusive and distinct honor of having
someone murdered as a result so
congratulations to her of course
on that huge uh huge uh
feather in her cat
and so uh that's interesting I mean he's
only 79 but you know what
you did it buddy
you did it here's a great clip this is
fun you know fresh and Fit I mean we
love these guys
um he's he's responded to the F our
Wednesday episode entitled Stephen
Crowder's getting divorced LOL or no
Stephen Crowder's wife left Tim Lowell
right and I am very proud of that title
in fact I saw a lot of uh people coping
hard over it
I was I was uh looking at the Stephen
Crowder subreddit and the conservative
subreddit just to get people's take and
I saw several people mention how uh
people are so gross and distasteful for
example I saw H3 battled his podcast
Stephen Crowder's wife left him low and
I mean that title is phenomenal
snowflakes shut the [__] up phenomenal
I feel like domestic uh verbal abuse is
is not tasteful to me personally yeah I
mean that's not my taste Stephen like of
all the people like you think Stephen
Crowder just go look at the titles of
that guy's videos like he's like the
king of like saying [__] horrible
offensive [__]
dude it's it's yeah but their whole take
was like I wouldn't make fun of divorce
and there's kids involved it's like
that's just evil I'm like this man
reenacted the murder of George Floyd for
a laugh let's not forget that and many
other but here's fresh and fit saying
that no actually Ila is the one planning
to divorce me because she started
exercising take a listen oh yeah record
scratch that right now if I'm not
mistaken L3 podcast is live talking
about this [__] right which which let me
go ahead and address uh you know eat
then decline if you guys know what I'm
saying [__] fat loser right he's over
here but you cannot call me a loser
while you hit your own record scratch
you can't do it you hear how loud the
dude in the background is laughing at
him just calling you was that a sound
effect I was actually a person Studio
right and decline yes fat loser right
but wait yeah that is questionable
because he said that like a hundred
times yeah and it was never fun it
wasn't that clever I mean well I've
heard it I like the name I think it is
clever but I've just heard it so many
times eat and decline right so eat then
decline if you guys know what I'm saying
[__] fat loser right he's over here
talking [__] about oh yeah look at this
Stephen Carter is getting uh divorced
they're all you know like that's exactly
what I said
it's awesome I think it is a sound bite
too leave it right
I didn't know this other [__] but let's
go okay so again this doesn't make any
sense he hit a Nelson sound laugh
like I was doing that but Nelson is like
the bully he's like the one that laughs
at people's Misfortune so in a way
correct I don't really feel that's a
criticism of me I feel like that means
I'm
you know
[__] cool dude I need to uh do Master
Class for him on how to use sound
effects because Zach it will never read
that's not happening yeah first you'd
have to install a brand new brain I mean
come on
there's a lot of steps in between about
oh yeah look at this Stephen Carter is
getting uh divorced haha and they're all
you know laughing at it and all this
other [__]
see I agree I agree yeah that's like
Nelson making fun of Crowder Yes what
we're doing right yeah we're we're the
Nelson in this case right and and I
agree I mean that's how that like haha
like it's a colloquial it means yeah
you're an idiot right so nice one there
let's go ahead and think about this real
quick
I don't know if you know this eat then
decline but your girl is not eating and
declining she's going to the gym in
training now this man is paying close
attention because yeah
I mean you have to be to know that you
have a little bit of a crush maybe
um
no he thinks she's ugly oh right right
right well somehow it's both it's
simultaneous she's going to the gym
she's training she's super hot but also
so ugly yeah
also I can't get over how much these
guys are always like I don't know
anything about Ethan who is Ethan also I
know everything about every detail of
his life his wife is exercising
fine but your girl is not eating and
declining she's going to the gym and
training
let's see here over on this side of the
internet we know one of the biggest
signs that your girl or your wife is
about to leave you right is what she
starts going to the gym why she's
preparing herself to get back out there
on the sexual Marketplace not only where
does he live again today right now where
is Ela right now is she preparing
literally this second right now well I
don't I don't want to uh oh being
impregnated Yeah by you Ethan usually
when the marriage is on the Rocks you
probably wouldn't have a third child
right also wouldn't be but I don't know
maybe Myron's right I mean is that Myron
yeah uh by Byron no Myron oh it is Myron
Myron Gaines I feel like she wouldn't be
going to the doctor to ensure you would
be spreading your seed more if she
wasn't if she wasn't really in this but
at the same time she is exercising and I
do love a world view where you become
paranoid take your significant other is
going to leave you because she starts
exercising right you know that's that's
just that's incredible way to see the
world my friend this will tie back in
later but maybe you guys should only
have one car you know that's what yeah
maybe that's why we don't need one car
one car that's all we ever need but um
yeah I mean dude come on so sad that you
would it's sad that you would even say
that like it's embarrassing that you
would even utter that
oh so it's such a self-report
right and also you're single in your
mid-30s Myron he's all the things he's
saying that you're gonna be soon exactly
you're a fan is there you're fantasizing
about my wife leaving me but the way I
see it is I'm about she's at least you
have a wife we're about to have a third
baby and you're sitting uh single in a
podcast crying about how the sexual
Marketplace isn't fair for men I mean my
God man
you're gonna die alone it's pretty
brutal when you really Break It Down
Like Jesus like you are gonna die alone
dude yeah for sure
and it's it's a shame because it didn't
have to be like that for you I feel like
there was
I don't think so ELO works out at home
does that matter based on his own logic
yeah I mean of course it doesn't matter
but based on his logic it doesn't make
[__] sense because she works out at
home
I think yeah well there it is okay so
I'm gonna have to I'm gonna have to get
serious about this she is exercising in
preparation for the third uh for the
third baby of course but
but I don't know if Myron knows this
because he doesn't have a kid's or a
significant other but
having giving birth is is pretty extreme
uh taxing
experience on the body I don't think he
knows much about that
she's posting photos of herself in the
process of doing so something that she
hadn't really done prior to this
situation I wonder why dude what the
[__] you got really following she's
posting the social media she's
she's feeling herself and she's doing it
as part of like a larger kind of
marketing thing and uh he's following
that very closely yeah must mean she's
doing a great job okay we got your eyes
true yeah right we got your follow
you my friend are also gonna go through
dude have you ever said a single word on
this podcast what are you even doing
here coconuts why is he speaking in all
hypotheticals none of this is true none
of this is real it's opposite day right
he's the literally Crowder's the one
getting a divorce Ethan's the one
thriving well admiring you're all alone
I feel like definitely oh yeah yeah yeah
out there on the sexual Marketplace not
only that she's posting photos of her
sexual marketing eBay
if we're not haggling on Craigslist what
do you mean sexual Marketplace you're a
grown man dude it's time to grow the
[__] up
sexual Marketplace my God herself and
the process of doing so something that
she hadn't really done prior to this
situation I wonder why so you my friend
I wonder why it says
what are we talking about I wonder why
wait what what are we talking about he's
got Byron just explained it you know
what coconuts and Barbados we call them
coconuts because inside his brain it's
like a game of of pong with two coconuts
I was bouncing back and forth Simpsons
where they cut the like inside Homer's
brain and it's like a black and white
cartoon of a monkey right no monkey's
got a little coconut and he's like right
in the symbols right right right right
so if Crowder right who has a
traditionally conservative wife and they
weren't that sexual experience prior to
the situation if he's getting divorced
if Tom Brady is getting divorced if all
these higher status guys are getting
divorced right and religion isn't even a
buffer guess what's gonna happen to you
fat ass you're probably gonna get
divorce as well how is that the
conclusion that you draw from that he
was so close he was so close to figuring
it out right the status
maybe those don't matter it doesn't it
doesn't matter maybe those don't matter
and that's right and this is the result
of that can you believe that these high
status religious men are being divorced
this guy who's not sexually experienced
and gets married really young if he
could get divorced anybody could get
divorced
have you considered maybe he's 12 Dan
bruh how old how long was Crowder
married five years or something no it
was like a decade oh 10 years yeah I
think it said they got married in 2012.
okay
yeah 2012. yeah but this whole thing is
him fantasizing about uh Ila leaving me
but I mean okay keep fantasizing I guess
she's not gonna she's not gonna [__] you
dude if that happens I guarantee that
you know divorced right and religion
isn't even a buffer guess what's gonna
happen to you fat ass you're probably
gonna get divorce as well
he's spitting right there damn do you
think that you're Dropped a Bomb in like
a really sad way do you think they're
trying to copy our our sound uh of
course though genius I noticed Stephen
Crowder was doing it too on some clips
but I mean it's because when we started
we had these little sound boards with
stupid little sound bites right and uh I
mean we're we didn't invent a soundboard
I know but we well you know we I feel
that we popularized it on YouTube shows
Definitely Maybe the only reason I would
say that I don't think he is is just
because like if you saw any of his ex
work you would not be doing what he's
doing like you would know how
embarrassing it is
yeah
say what
I feel like Harper notes in Barbados
right now what wait what are we talking
about I'm just saying he didn't copy us
okay I wonder why
but I do feel like to be fair the
obviously we did not invent the sound
biting stuff and we're always giving
credit to Fred Norris
but I don't think anyone did it on
YouTube
brought that level of production
and that's what I'm here and that's what
I'm proud of
hit that Foghorn Zach
I I would never even stoop down to uh
you don't have that you don't even have
it on them
I'm sorry record scratch I got that
but that's just like ironic you know
can you get a Foghorn just feel like we
need it just you know when when the
irony you mean like the party horn thing
the party horn
yeah party horn
but these guys as usual with H3 and all
these other [__] you know libtard
podcasts like lassan fagabi does he
really Jesus dude does he really use
that as a slay that you can't say that
bro like holy [__] these guys are so
[__] different also what was the
inflection on that slur it's like he
didn't want to fully say it he's so
weird
you're the best bro big oof you're so
cool for that and L3 podcast itself he's
like I refuse to grow up since I was in
Middle School I was keep saying those
words
sure they love to kick people when
they're down and talk [__] and give
their stupid ass commentary yeah Crowder
who's a [__] hypocrite and a piece of
[__]
and a wife abuser it turns out as well
I'm telling you bro I'm not wishing a
divorce on you because I wish no divorce
on any man just fantasized about it for
like five minutes talking about what is
this just doing it bro you ain't far
from it either my friend and we already
are seeing because and so he says you're
not far from a divorce why one reason
I'm fat
you're fat Ela works out and because
Crowder got divorced therefore you're
probably gonna get divorced I think it
really boils down to me being fat yeah
if I can be totally fair but uh
so that is pretty compelling evidence I
must say evidence of it but obviously
you being a blue pilled simp and not
understanding how women work and how bro
you're single married with Children bro
how do women work
bro he probably doesn't do he probably
doesn't perform well in the sexual
Marketplace at all bro you are forever
alone
you are probably on the verge of divorce
as well my friend because a girl going
to the gym and training is one of the
biggest telltale signs that she's about
to leave your dumb ass anyway ELO will
be calling in a little bit to uh update
us on the status of her uh uh embryo
yeah so she may be getting pregnant for
the third time
which I think is a sign that uh divorce
is coming I don't know
but you want to see that because you're
too busy eating and declining uh what
was that uh quote again coconuts and
Barbados bro you were so dumb
oh
wait I want to hear what he has to say I
know I should have taken by it it's like
it's dude you are so coconuts and
Barbados don't try to hide it it's just
who you are some Barbados oh no no
coconuts are divorce yeah I mean that
wasn't even that wasn't enough parody it
was a play on words
let me I need to hear all of it again I
need to hear it set up in the punchline
you feel bad for him yeah I mean
he's just it's almost sweet how dumb he
is you it got ahead it's kind of cute
but even sitting on that one
he thought about that yeah yeah he
hasn't said really yeah he's a divorce
but you're the guy with the Coconuts
what is coconut you know what I mean I
don't have the Coconuts you do
if you were getting divorced maybe
coconuts and divorce although it's still
not that clever it doesn't rhyme it's
not a play on words you just change one
word I do appreciate that he gave us a
new coconuts and Barbados uh sound bite
though did you now we have a new variant
of it
[Music]
I mean you know how you laugh when
something isn't that fun but it's kind
of like hey yeah it's like okay come on
all right our coconuts you got one Ally
here is a coconuts and Barbados
meditating deeply uh on what day picking
coconuts in Barbados
picking coconuts and Barbie eating
antique there you go down uh what was
that uh quote again coconuts and
Barbados oh no no coconuts are divorced
coconuts
okay camouflage what's your support in
in the chat for coconuts and and divorce
they like that no just a few they like
it somebody said Same Love hmm
okay
but again
save that for when I actually get
divorced
I'm not divorced yeah why is he trying
to drag you down like let's you know
what you mean save that because I am
still married
man it is Wednesday man it is Wednesday
man
I man I love coconuts
let's just invite him I would love that
no Byron or Myron do you think he would
call in by himself hell no no but I
would love that scared yeah he's like a
baby he needs he needs daddy Myron okay
well there it is I thought that was fun
I always love to hear from them the
goons
at uh fresh and fit
you gotta think of it when you think of
a funding you're that no Crowder just
put out a statement on Twitter but it's
cool we love these Live Oak dudes
we haven't seen the video first but I
I want to watch it now [__] it
we're gonna we're gonna get to all this
okay over here video too oh we are
juicing today this is why I'm watching
oh God
okay so obviously we're going out of
order because you we haven't even
watched the video together yet but this
is breaking news
he said I commented on my ongoing
divorce on Tuesday
requesting privacy in the best interest
of the family but also by court order
agreed upon by all parties you you then
you broke that court order right by
talking about it you literally said I
chose wrong and that she left you which
was a lie broken marriages are ugly and
then people do ugly things myself of
course included and I would never claim
otherwise
however due to recent misleadingly
edited leaks
to the Tabloid press without context and
not subject to consequences of the Court
well if not privacy
the next best option is truth are we
getting tea
Stephen Crowder who's getting back to
this we got to walk for the sake of the
audience we got to go through this
chronology you think we'll come back to
this
we'll come back to it
so they're gonna it's a Crowder who's so
concerned about his kids welfare is
about to have a public spat let's go
with his ex-wife
the mother of his kids well let's see
can you preview his statement while
we're going through stuff baby thank you
all right so um
where are we so let's just get into the
Crowder stuff do it
so yesterday A A leaked video
um
his video statement is literally what
his text says oh he just wrote it as
well as said it on video exactly okay so
I guess we've seen the state so then I
can't wait for
oh my God this is this is such a l for
him your fault it's your fault bro
now before we watch this video I think
it's important to know
that
this video took place
four days after we Sam cedared him it
sure did
which like
we'll come back to it I do think that we
potentially derailed this man's whole
life I mean obviously not slowly so
now I never wanted this to happen to his
wife of course or his kids but to be
fair she says this was happening for
years
yeah no for sure but I do like
definitely having a bad week let's put
it on a rough week yeah
wow that that interview has three
million views okay Stephen
it's iconic I can be that I've had
multiple people that don't watch like
you know extended friends of mine and
family that don't really watch the show
that know about that and that's awesome
yeah
okay so here's the video and I will
definitely give trigger warnings
this depicts a verbal he's he's verbally
abusing his uh pregnant yeah if you
can't handle like it's crazy narcissists
like [__] toxic relationship stuff
that you probably want to dip out for a
few minutes because this is pretty
brutal
it's very gross
now it's worth noting right at the top
his wife here is eight months pregnant
with twins
now if you're eight months pregnant with
a child one baby you're basically
you can it's hard to do anything
and uh a halfway decent significant
other would be bending over backwards to
cater to help to make sure they're
comfortable to do stuff for them
um look how she's massive but she has
twins okay so let that uh set the stage
here gradual boundaries
no no you just did you just did it I
drew a boundary and abusive you were not
taking a car because if you refuse to do
right for things then I will go pick up
the groceries okay my groceries
steaks wood pellets for my grill
now
he's mad that his eighth month old
pregnant with twins wife did not is not
going grocery shopping
and doing wifey things
um
when you're at eighth month you're
basically ready to have a kid the other
weird thing is that Steven Crowder has
one car this man is wealthy he's
successful
he's obviously enjoying a nice day in a
beautiful house with a pool
um he has one car to control her
yeah that is the only reason he has one
car they're arguing about who can use
the car which is you know obscene like
the uh
also right off the bat can we draw
attention to the fact that he's kick
back relaxing with the cigar blowing
smoke into his eight-month pregnant
wife's face as he's berating her this
man is smoking a cigar in front of his
eight-month pregnant wife trying to make
his kids Alpha you know the kids who by
the way he cares most about in this
world who has learned about their
physical safety
he emphasized that over and over right
that seems in contradiction
he also in the video from Wednesday we
did says uh
the kids are not to blame
I think he I think he [__] hates his
kids I think he blames the kids I think
he definitely blames the kids because
that's that was so out of pocket yeah uh
here here your fault
how about you first
how do you wish that
and I will ask someone
would you like me to ask right she's
trying to go somewhere she she has to
ask permission who do you want me to ask
I need to go somewhere
still responds with is that a threat
like what she's at actually I'm I'm sad
because she's being so compliant and so
um submissive to him what seems to be
out of fear you know she's tiptoeing her
she's trying not to set him off trying
and failing so she says okay you're not
gonna let me take the card then who do
you want to pick me up you can decide
because apparently you're
insecure and afraid of something
else
an Uber he says to his eight-month
pregnant wife with two kids whose
security he is utmost concerned about
that's psychotic that's hateful it's
like vengeful it's disgusting get an
Uber he said to her
while sitting there puffing a cigar this
man is
psychotic yeah
okay Stephen
some constraints like I can't see it
listen to me listen to me you want to
walk out right now listen to me I can't
go to the gym I can't go to my parents
listen to this baby cry to his pregnant
wife about how this [__] boy [__]
loser this is an alpha
is this an alpha this man is crying to
his pregnant wife that he can't go to
the gym he can't hang out with his
friends shut the [__] up dude you are
such a [__] loser bro it's
embarrassing not because and and in
addition to the whole abusive thing
which is horrific but you present
yourself as a alpha you wear a gun strap
this is [__] you're a little boy
you're a [__] [__] you are a child
you're worse than a child you're a
spoiled brat [__] child your dad
[__] you up that's for sure
yeah I thought about uh well anyway I'll
I'll mention it later emailing that
checking in on the dad yeah see if they
want to call in
I can't call my friends I can't call my
friends you're gonna take the car
I don't have my Stakes honey you need to
go grocery shopping you I don't have my
steaks take an Uber how about you use
[__] Postmates loser
you're rich she's pregnant
what a [__] demon he is
demonic leave me here Hillary just think
of how boxing bugs dude I'll get it I'll
be back on and back no that doesn't work
either I do work either
like literally whining
it doesn't work for me either
like what the [__] my three-year-old
doesn't whine that hardcore baby baby
sad Crowder
baby wants baby wants steak
what do you need me to pick up I'll get
it okay she's okay I'll take the car
I'll pick up whatever groceries you want
dude that doesn't work
no that doesn't work either
baby will start to cry did I hope he
disappears he needs to disappear after
this
yeah well it's like it's wild because I
mean she looks like she's ready to pop
oh yeah oh she is so it's it's it's
I just can't comprehend how psychotic it
is that she's even grocery shopping
she's literally barefoot and pregnant in
their backyard and he's sitting on the
couch blowing cigar smoke into her face
because she's about to go do [__] for
him look at his body his body language
too
such a dick
well
so this is the family values this is the
tradition that the alpha males want
that's right fight like hell brother
baby bite like hell now I personally
consider not being I think being
confident and secure
and uh
not a hateful piece of [__] that's Alpha
I mean you're crying you're crying and
[__] and spitting
that's childish that is straight beta
Behavior brother cry cry baby
can you grab a sound bite of him going
that doesn't work either sure yeah I can
do that that's gonna be an important one
I think that's either wait let me go
back
hey
ah
I'm gonna send I'm so glad in a sense
that this came out because
this is
Seaman just joined
holy [__]
I just looked over on my screen and see
man is in the lobby what the [__]
what do we do I I don't want to
interrupt this whole I don't want to
interrupt it either I sent an email I
said we're going to finish our segment
and then we'll let you in well it's late
enough hopefully that's risky
yeah we might lose him
uh I can't I can't I gotta no we gotta
finish this we gotta I got it as much as
I wanna talk to C man
yeah uh again it's just I'm glad this is
out because
it really shows like in a real way that
these hateful bigoted homophobic racist
people are genuinely just really bad
people they're disgusting they're
hateful
and they're afraid that the world is
changing where uh they can't be open
Psychopaths to the people in their there
I love it I love it wife and kids oh
[__] much
it's such like a 50s mentality death you
know yeah yeah
um
it's sickening
and look at him like he's sitting in
this beautiful house [__] gorgeous
Mansion this beautiful pool got a
pregnant wife he's got a dog he's
smoking car yeah he's Rich he has
everything that he advocates for he has
constructed this life to a t to this
idealized version of himself and what
did it bring you Stephen
everyone thinks you're a [__] loser
your wife leaves you and you're just you
have nothing fully exposed [__]
pathetic or fully exposed it's just
you're fully exposed and look how sad
you are you're sitting there and you
have it all and you're still sad you're
crying you're crying like a child you're
alone now
you're you're [__] and pissing
it doesn't work for me either
that's you Stephen she was working so
hard to try and just
cap off whatever anger he has here like
she kept saying I'll do this for you
I'll do this for you full of easement
it's always you need to make things
harder you need to make things harder
that's literally how it always works
she's clearly
scared of him yeah uh here we'll
continue
wait is he really wearing a fight like
hell's shirt in the video yeah
yeah that I I don't think many people
knew that's what he meant
now that's a good sound drop go play
that again shout out to uh blizzard
wolfier mod go ahead
I mean that sounds like a Tim hi Decker
doing a character and here we have you
Stephen Crowder the alpha
the cultural Force
crying and [__] like a child go
ahead Zach
how embarrassing
how miserable
and yes I Relish in it because you are a
bad person in fact
very bad
[Music]
an evil person
and so I rub my hands together and while
I wish the best of course I support his
wife and kids uh to the fullest extent
possible
he does seem like a danger to them so
I'm glad yeah I'm glad they're separated
but yes I sit here and relish every
second of this Stephen because
this means that you're done
oh what a [__] nightmare and and
that's such a win for the world
and now you're a hack you're not funny
at all
and uh your friends are leaving the show
you're leprechaun homie just being a
shitty boss your leprechaun homie just
fully exposed you about how insecure you
are I audition was a stand-up guy
everyone had the daily wire [__]
hates your guts like you have no allies
you're surrounded your wife left you and
candy on the war path it's so you just
said no to 50 million dollars I bet
you'll regret that pretty soon
and now [__] stupid bro and now dude
you're about to go bald as I absorb your
hairline
laughs
yes Stephen it's uh it's a sad sad sight
does it work for you
I had no idea this was going to happen
me neither
we knew uh does this mean
it doesn't work for him we're in your
walls Stephen
yeah
bro don't have to think about it dude
just disappear man
you know nobody wants to hear see from
you again and I think that's better for
everybody no
but let's continue
this man is obscenely selfish my life is
set to the second
he says to his pregnant wife you are
kicked back in your backyard smoking a
cigar you're not doing [__]
it doesn't work for me dude
I love that's my favorite soundtrack
it was fully encapsulate just what a
[__] he is
[Music]
the cigar just really puts it all over
the top also what the [__] does that
mean the only way out of this is
discipline and receiving he was watching
too much Cobra Kai I think at the time
it means you listen to me discipline and
you respect me that's right right yeah
he's just saying you will do what I say
when I say it
to me it Feels Like A Veiled Threat
the only way out of this yeah definitely
there's like a sense of or else yeah
when he's saying that for sure there's a
lot of that throughout this
video
I just said the only way out of this is
disciplinary
I love you but Stephen figures
sick
also like the mentality of a woman that
deeply pregnant it's so much hormones
and thoughts and emotions when you're
that close to pregnancy
um
her mental state must have been just
just I feel so horrible for her to deal
with this while being that close to
pregnancy or to giving birth it's it's
and she's the one who's being forced to
sound grounded insane because she's
scared of him
she's desperately trying to appease him
watch it watch it that's another threat
when he says that by the way she takes a
step back
right I noticed that too which
could possibly mean that Something's
Happened
they both say there was no physical
violence but
the way he's speaking is really I
wouldn't be surprised yeah I wouldn't be
surprised at all it's very threatening
watch it watch it
Hawks were like a child that's crazy
[__] watch it [__] watch it
and I I need some space we need to do
something baby for a little bit okay I
love you
I love you very much
I don't love it that's the big brother
uh
yes Family Values my friend that doesn't
work either
I Love You Stephen I don't love you as a
good Christian man
horrible
I've never received love from you and
the fact is when I don't look I need to
do a b c and b just because now but I
love you more of life itself okay put on
some gloves now that's not fair it's not
fair and it's disingenuate
so the glove thing uh it's
detailed in the article which we'll read
his dog requires some kind of medicine
and she was concerned that the medicine
could be toxic to the children
and so she was like can you do it I'm
assuming because it's toxic and he says
if you love me you will expose yourself
to these potentially toxic
fumes
and I mean there's so much to unpack
there
I mean again he talks about the safety
of his kids this man hates his kids he
literally exposing them to toxic [__]
fumes
and
again that's not what love is Stephen
Stephen is not you do what I say he goes
he says I ask you to do things a b c d
and you say you love me
the [__] bro
this is when I go look I need an A B C
dude no but I love you more than life
itself okay put on some gloves itself
that's not fair like he's it's all it's
like he is intentionally torturing and
tormenting her
that's a sick dude right there man
it's up there and it's disintended
Hillary you're right right now become
someone he says become someone to the
woman he's forced to stay home
be a housewife
refuses to give her access to a car
controls every aspect of her life you
need to become someone
okay give me a car let's start there
oh what happened
disingenuate
Hillary you're right right
become someone
day in and day out working up a wife
is there any um
is there any obligation to be a worthy
husband
I'm genuinely curious if he thinks that
he has any obligation to be
that's that's it making money
and that that entitles him to be a
complete psychopath to dude I'm telling
you this guy would torture his kids man
he I don't think he likes his kids I
hate to say it but like I I genuinely
don't think
and you guys will well another reason he
didn't show up to the birth yeah
which we'll find out when we read the
article this man didn't go to the birth
of his kids
who talks all day about the importance
of family
and marriage
I mean shut the like just shut up if
this is your life you cannot tell
anybody about marriage and family it's
just so ridiculous because every single
thing in that video goes directly
against what he was trying to portray in
his original video oh yeah my wife none
of this was my fault none of it was my
fault it was this was her choice like no
it [__] wasn't it looks like you made
it pretty [__] difficult
yeah and the the Dig he levels at her
about I chose wrong really uh is
is Meaningful when you see this whole
thing
come on now I'm not gonna engage
I the fact that she's even like text me
what you need
uh
uh is stunning display of just how
scared she is of him
you're not committed to anything you're
not committed to anything
you just said I love you I'm committed
walk the dogs put on some gloves
he is eight months pregnant with twins
walk the dogs
you [__] loser
I mean you walk the dogs yes she's going
and doing [__] for you go walk your damn
dogs and put their medicine on it's not
easy to walk
right it's tough especially when you're
a boy
dude I mean it's it's stunning it's
stunning
are you committed the interesting thing
too is like he's very wealthy they could
have help they could have uh groceries
delivered they could have a second car
they can have someone to walk their dog
and clean their house easily but he
insists
on making her do it
as some strange gesture that she's
willing to suffer that's how she shows
her loved him by suffering
Show Me Your Love by walking the dogs
what are you saying man
she actually thought about it which is
heartbreaking she picked up the dog
leash here you see that she actually
thought about walking the dogs yep
that's heartbreaking man
she picks up the leaves
she's about to do it and she's like [__]
I'm sick good for you man oh God
as Crowder heads inside Steven gets
angry and angry and by his own admission
screams I will [__] you up to her
now this I guess is
uh it's not on video but they know it
because
he got a whole bunch of documents and
videos and it actually specifically said
that uh he claims he heard the audio of
it but the family that shared all of
this with him the family of the wife uh
didn't want most of it published but
allowed him to listen to it oh so he did
hear it uh yeah according to the article
he heard that evidence that that
happened and that's why he says by
Stephen's own admission
as well
so that's the video that came out there
you go he's so strong
yeah yeah I mean really
it's almost it's interesting how fresh
and fit put it but what's what's
actually it's a testament to her
strength that despite the religion uh
pressure despite the abusive husband she
was and like you saw she almost walked
the dog she almost submitted but
um
she found the strength to
leave that horrible situation
now I think it's worth at this time
uh reading the article
I can just read these bullet points I
guess but there's there's a lot of extra
details in this original article at
yashar.substack.com this is a guy who
broke the story
and um
I'll read uh the highlights he said the
ring camera footage documented the
moments leading up
to where Stephen said I will [__] you up
the audio of this incident was reviewed
by the author but the family requested
only the outside portion of the video be
posted
and audio files and text messages the
author reviewed Stephen Crowder admits
to some of his faults which include a
volcanic temper repeatedly and at times
regretfully
so I'm assuming that
She and Him had a lot of text
conversations after this
where he was probably like I'm so sorry
or whatever yeah of course and so he saw
Stephen essentially admitting to all
this
this story is based on conversations
with multiple sources none of whom would
speak to the author unless they were
granted
and amenity
anonymity
and an anonymity anonymity
the night before she gave birth Stephen
and Hillary exchanged a series of text
messages about separating
Hillary sent her husband one of the
final text messages Stephen she said
quote Stephen I'm afraid of you and your
rage you are scary you scare me I want
to heal things but you have to take
responsibility stop blaming others stop
feeling pain and sadness only for
yourself
his very private wife who hardly appears
in public and is rarely photographed had
made a request via her attorney that her
husband would not discuss the divorce at
all
that agreement he broke
on his Show when he said when he talked
extensively about it he said there was
no abuse that was a lie he said
it was uh he picked wrong about her
actually a small correction I just want
to point out he was very specific of
saying there was no physical abuse
okay
well it was misleading
right well but in retrospect I think
it's interesting that he chose to
specify physical abuse because obviously
emotional abuse was occurring
I find it interesting that he said that
at all
that he felt the need to say it yeah
yeah he got baited into it by candy
[__] noans like what the hell but
yeah so he he broke their agreement that
they legally made between their
attorneys not to talk about it to throw
a dig at her and to cover his own ass
and in response they put out this video
so to everyone who's like yo it's tacky
that she put this out or whatever
she put this out in response to what
Stephen said
and June 2021 Stephen left their home to
pursue an elective
surgery you guys remember I had that
crazy uh intense heart surgery or
whatever it was an elective surgery
gender affirming perhaps he has a
condition with a concave chest I think
yeah he got Top surgery right that's
gender affirming surgery for him well
and I think some people can experience
complications from that and it becomes a
necessary Medical
uh procedure but I don't from what I
understand his was cosmetic and totally
elective as I understand it
and he did this right before his wife
was going to give birth
so all of a sudden he becomes he put
himself in the position to be the one
that needs to be cared for and looked
after as she's about to give birth to
twins
and he has complications from it there's
fluid in his lungs
and uh he actually became very sick he
and yeah from it and he chose not to
attend the birth of his twins
this man did not attend the birth of his
twins
and the best part
is in the video Stephen put out he
continues to say this is her choice he
makes that he makes that point oddly so
many times she's doing this to me she's
leaving me because the state of Texas
allows it she's leaving me she's leaving
me
well according to documents uh actually
Hillary was unaware that Stephen had
hired a divorce attorney before she ever
did
Crowder months before she saw a divorce
hired a divorce attorney and told his
assistants to cut her off financially
which is illegal by the way
very legal and in divorce court he's
going to get absolutely [__] for doing
that good good
during divorce you're not allowed to
partition funds or do anything like that
I hope she gets everything
I just want the kids taken care of so
yeah
but he he's definitely get his ass
handed to him for that cut her off
financially
it's vindictive
and and it shows a callousness for the
kids too
right Crowder's definitely going to be
like that every other weekend dad he's
putting himself before
anybody he doesn't care he just cares
what happens to him
and again this guy has the [__] balls
to sit there like the moral support
superiority and tell and lecture like
black communities on having single
family homes that that's like the
scourge of America you are creating one
you scum [__]
laughs
you scum
you hypocrite you loser
you didn't even go to their birth you
cowered
so again Steven's the one that got the
divorce attorney first
and he lied about it the cover is ass
now there's been a lot of
Ila Ila just finished at the doctor
we're currently on our way to the doctor
tell Ella to call him when they're done
yeah
or she can call in nice call him when
she's done yeah
now there's been a pretty interesting
reaction to this on Twitter
the original author of this article
posted a 20-second clip
which in my opinion
was a kind of a mistake because it
really should have posted the whole
thing it really doesn't capture
even close to
and it gave room to a lot of his fans
who are not going to go read the article
or watch the full video to say
what's the big story here it's just the
argument 20 seconds of an argument out
of context and you see a lot of people
doing that
but there's been a lot of
mixed bags I mean a lot of his fans are
are definitely
disgusted
but there's a lot who and this is the
biggest self-report ever
they're saying this is normal
they're saying this is a normal
conversation that I have with you
significant other once a week me and my
wife argue like this what's the big deal
which is just it's these this is the
people that
are telling women they cannot have
abortions
the this man is smoking he's blowing
cigar smoke and his pregnant wife's face
and telling everybody they can't have
abortions
pro-life I'd look like maybe and there's
a whole bunch of his fans who think this
is fine the full video shows Crowder
trying to reason with her what she
refuses to do you believe that that's a
real person she wants
she wants and she wants and she will not
be asked to do a dang thing lazy what a
lazy eight month pregnant that's abuse
from her
he even offered alternatives to just
taking off in the one car they seem to
have which is reasonable
I
I guarantee you this person's Pro
pro-life or forced birth as I like to
call it
a quartering of course uh our favorite
came out uh to defend Crowder who is
married
somehow
remember when everyone was super sure
that Amber Heard was being abused just
saying
uh-huh
I don't know what you want bro there's a
video
there's like a video
I just watched like a video of this man
blowing cigar smoke in his pregnant's
wife's face and telling her to take an
Uber basically irrefutable evidence I
mean
come on dude you said it yourself
uh right wing cope a great uh Twitter uh
account which we love why would I listen
to relationship analysis from you
considering you urinate in your own
basement as Revenge after your wife got
pizza Without You Fair Point that's a
fair point good analysis by uh right
wing cope hahaha I peed in my basement
oh he bailed out deleted my Crowder
tweets I'll hold the L willingly but as
always I'll wish for the best and hope
there's more context we're not seeing
okay
that's a good sign because that showed
they even quartering supporters were
enough like dude what the [__] he's
definitely in the wrong yeah but he he
he adds a
a footnote I am not picking sides I
still support Stephen oh well then you
are picking up Jeremy I don't support
you
he says people shouldn't have said
anything people make mistakes
that doesn't make them worth abandoning
bro you are abandoned yes I mean this
has been you can even watch in the video
it's clear to anybody that has any
understanding of like
has any
gram of empathy that she's been dealing
with this for a long time
this is not an isolated incident and the
article says as much
shout out to all these uh verified
accounts by the way this is not abuse my
God how insulting to women who actually
get terribly abused she's living a
lavish lifestyle and clearly he's
getting concerned she's not being a wife
anymore just a freeloader Money Changes
women real quick hold on this is like a
12 year old what is who is it I mean of
course that's all of Steven's fans
can you I I genuinely can you do I want
to know how old this person is if you
can yeah don't pull it up but I I want
you literally have their handle on
screen right now
if you're worried about like directing
hate no it's already happening I'm just
letting you know listen I'm not trying
to pull it up I just want you to tell me
how old it is
thank you I don't know they're I mean
it's a public tweet it's verified I mean
you you chose to wrote that dumb [__]
yeah I mean I don't care I just was
pointing out that
a woman actually comes out uh free the
world she's I don't see the big deal
he's being a jerk but I didn't hear
physical threats and he's saying he will
be left without a car if she takes it
somewhere too Etc I'd need more
background to judge this three-minute
interaction I didn't hear the threats
the article claimed happened
that's really incredible to me that uh
here's another one the more
you can always tell how crazy someone is
by how many emojis
Jesus America emojis they have in their
handle nobody knows what was happening
before people say bad [__] when they're
angry
and he was sitting outside what does
sitting outside have to do with it
everybody knows the rule you're allowed
to [__] abuse be verbally abusive as
long as it's outside Take It Outside
that's that's what that expression means
y'all come from stable household you all
come from stable households and it shows
right
is that I mean right is just saying this
isn't a big deal lots of households are
like this oh
right
well it's kind of a
I don't think he's saying or they're
saying what they think they're saying
they're like yeah you've seen normal
relationships and you know how insane
this is
unlike me I'm proud that I grew up in an
unstable house right
John Curtis shout out to a verified user
John Curtis incredibly ridiculous for
you to share this personal exchange as
if it were a worthy story I'm not sure
what your end goal is but I can tell you
now that it won't be successful and will
only result with more unnecessary drama
take this down
all right John
I don't know how these people are real
uh here's another one James Hugh note to
self disconnect the darn ring cameras
I love that be more paranoid
be even more paranoid I just realize me
berating my wife on a daily basis is all
being captured on camera I better
disconnect those I the ring cameras were
set up to catch the people outside
but the real enemies were inside the
house the whole time
note to self Winston good man yes spy
more on your significant others
uh Matt Lutz I'm not saying Crowder is
never verbally abused her okay thanks
good next
he may have but this just looks like a
normal marital argument to me and for
all the people saying but she's pregnant
you don't get to escape all the
responsibility because of that who are
you
if this is a normal marital argument
your wife is in big trouble
if you are married God forbid
I mean
these are the idols man it's just it's
stunning it's awesome that they all have
blue check marks by the way it really
has verified baby the dumbest
[__] on the platform
oh yeah uh here's another one normal
marital argument for a blue check mark
maybe that's good
right implying of course the people with
blue check marks are life abusers which
is a fair assumption I think that's fair
okay
I mean I didn't pay for mine or nothing
but not I I think that you know the joke
being that the conservatives are
treating it like uh
Elon Musk patreon this is relatively
innocuous clearly their marriage is
having issues and they get into the
arguments I married and always isn't
always sunshine and rainbows we often
regret things we have said In the Heat
of the Moment
brother you hate your wife yeah you
you're you're mentally ill man seek help
that's what they always say right I have
arguments with my wife
I've been married to my wife for 10
years it's a long time been together for
15.
right you're good parallel because you
what year did you get married in
it was uh
2013 2013. I don't I'm kidding yeah or
12 12 or 13. so you were married right
around the same time as Stephen Crowder
you guys have Peril and you're the same
age as parallel life path now we've had
we have fights right and the thing is
when you fight with your significant
other because you respect them as a
person you there's places that you don't
go things that you don't say because
even though you're mad at them you still
respect them you don't want to hurt them
or damage your relationship that's
not something he's doing
uh my keyboard's not working oh here oh
[__]
unresponsive oh it's okay let's not
pretend that you are anyone for that
matter hasn't oh this is a response to
me let's not pretend that you or anyone
for that matter hasn't ever had simmer
heated discussions disagreements
arguments with your other half why do
people have a lot to say about others
relationship when you have worse going
on in your own life home bro why do you
again
such as self-report I have worse going
on in my life based on what
according to them I'm getting divorced
and I beat my wife in their imagination
yeah
um
why do people have a lot to say about
what's going on in other relationships
you know I wouldn't but Stephen is
really interested what goes on in other
people's relationships that's the thing
that's like like these people saying oh
this is like this is way too personal
and this is like not appropriate to get
aired out I honestly frankly would
normally yeah agree totally that that's
a little invasive to like be watching
their ring camera footage but Stephen
Crowder has built a career aft like
directly contradicting everything that
you witness in this video it's way too
on the nose to not
to not point out they'll almost do I
don't want to say celebrate but uh two
let's say I'm glad his life is falling
apart I am celebrating that savior yeah
love it we're savoring the irony
unabashedly so and again he's just a
real evil piece of [__] so this really
validates that you know
um so lots of self-reports there from
his audience who say no this is totally
normal
this is T right here you guys this is
even before the ring footage leaked I
saw this here's his wife on Instagram
chief of the fupa Trooper who yo this is
somebody from our community uh-oh and so
this is before this video drops so this
was like piping hot
she only follows 77 people
four of which is betrayal trauma
recovery coach
narcissist abuse recovery coach marriage
coach
and
she follows candy
is at this moment his like arch nemesis
who invited her on her show despite
Stephen she follows him
follows her and the daily wire I think
too
so that's [__] real interesting
this felt more significant before we saw
that video because now it's almost like
oh yeah no [__] yeah um but yeah the
fact that uh you know she's following
candy is still pretty awesome
um interesting which only follows 77
people
yeah like one of them are about
recovering from an abusive relationship
right
sad man she thought she was marrying
like a good Christian guy and uh Well
turns out he's a [__] psycho people
re these evil Psychopaths like him they
hide behind the religion they use it to
justify
being evil selfish narcissistic
judgmental bigoted homophobic
they wear it like a shield protects them
to be as evil and [__] debased and
nasty it's possible
and they say that's what Jesus would
want for me
Jesus would want you to get an Uber
obviously Jesus wants your ass to go
grocery shopping right now
Jesus wants me to eat a steak
it's the most important thing in my life
right now
Praise Jesus Praise Jesus
um
and of course our favorite candy
is uh responding she was quick to
respond boy she was like let's go she
put this out like five minutes after
that video she probably had a heads up
to be honest because I I do actually
believe that the author of that article
has some association with Ben Shapiro is
he a conservative guy yeah I think so oh
he is I don't know anything they're like
radical Centrist type dude I I recognize
the name
um but yeah there's a decent chance uh
they had a heads up
um
my girlfriend he minha turned 21. [__]
you
21 21
[__] you Ximena Ximena Jimena yes so uh
shout out now again Candace Owens is a
monster
but I love to see him fight
candy
been here since 2013 wife watched
through her veterinarian doctorate
program and I'm on my last year for
pharmacy one thanks for carrying us
through all the undergrad and
Professional School cover all 9 000
taste buds game wow going all the way
back okay that's a 10. thank you guys
so let's let's watch candy Revel in uh
his demise tap into before we get to it
I just want to back up and tell you why
we are discussing this breaking news
because it's occurred to me that there
are some people out there who believe
that to be a conservative what it means
is that we become tribal and we defend
other conservatives even I'm sorry this
is so ironic she if she didn't have like
the spat with him she would want I feel
like she'd be
she'd be out there defending him because
you know she oh she talks about tribal
she's the most tribal person she is
tribal politics
but hey I'll take what I can get the
things that are wrong that we don't
discuss things that can cancel on our
own side because we need to just make
sure that we score wins in other ways
and that is wrong so that to me is the
exact opposite of why I have this
platform I am not tribal I want to
expose things when they are bad on the
left and I will also expose things when
they are bad on the right obviously I
have been interested in the Stephen
Crowder Saga pertaining to his divorce
because he literally inserted me into
his divorce a couple of days ago and his
wife and family are now speaking out
regarding that video in which he told
people publicly that his wife was
leaving him you remember this he chose
wrong and he essentially made it sound
as if he did not want his marriage to
end but his wife simply wanted to leave
well she has responded by giving video
and I want to change she's probably just
going to go over uh
what we did yeah we don't have to watch
but it is interesting like the daily
wire I mean this is
the biggest conservative uh media
New Media conglomerate
and they're all going in on Stephen
which is phenomenal has anyone like Ben
Shapiro commented on this kind of stuff
I wonder no I think Ben
has tried to stay out of all of the
Crowder stuff even when all that drama
was going on I don't think
uh you know what actually I think at one
point he did make a video about it but
yeah he's like the face of the network
it makes sense that they wouldn't want
it candy that's what Candy's there for
right right it's the sling the money so
let her do her job what is Jordan
Peterson think
about it's just a marital spout
me and my wife have a worse arguments
regularly up yours
this this is what you're angry about you
should see how cranky I get after a
month of eating only meat
my God
holy
um
other Crowder stuff before we get to see
man we'll get to him soon thank you just
to uh put a cap on what a great guy
Stephen is
on the same day was it the same day or
was the day before
this video leak came out he decided to
just make fun of people with Trent Down
syndrome for no [__] reason at all
why
because he's a giant piece of [__] he
posted this to Twitter an excerpt from
his show that he was so proud of the
world's first
but children the opportunity play with
this doll is breaking barriers
fashion doll yeah it's so evil it's like
bro grow the [__] up you know what's
crazy about this even [__] Matt Walsh
was like I don't understand why people
are upset about this is a this is a good
thing
I'm not kidding I was like shocked when
I saw it
wait this is this is actually a thing in
conservatives fear to make fun of people
with Down Syndrome not a not all of the
conservatives here here
that show The Leftovers did I know by
the way I know some conservatives are
calling this quote woke but I don't see
it that way it's pro-life the left is
Exterminating Down syndrome children
okay so yeah it's not exactly uh well at
least he's being consistent but he says
they're victims of actual and actual
Eugenics campaign this is one case where
inclusion and representation is actually
important
so I mean she's a dumbass [__]
hypocrite but like even Matt Walsh was
not willing to go that far so listen to
these [__] morons pathetic losers
having the first fashion doll yeah with
[__] strength allowing more children
restart
we don't say that word Stephen
recharge strength allowing more children
dunking on young girls with down sync
very cool yep those little girls with
Down Syndrome David David sitting real
high on their purse literally about time
they get taken down one
is that their future through fashion
doll play and imagine what is possible
Mattel Barbie's parent company announced
well here's the thing tell me what's
wrong with that Stephen really I've been
going full board Mattel actually
announced plans to expand this in the
name of diversity uh before the end of
the year with sickle cell Barbie oh for
those so that's something they also
such a bad joke even it's like not even
funny bro
thanks
I mean you should have gone with some
you know I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
yeah don't don't I got ideas don't try
and get into the offensive Olympic with
uh Steven Crouch I have ideas for other
Barbies that would have been funnier
okay but I'm not gonna go there because
I'm [__] Saint compared to him
it shows bro
so I mean this guy's just spreading the
love you know what I mean uh
who would have thought that this dude
who shits on the girl with Down Syndrome
would be such an [__] right shocking
don't work either
that's the best
um
yeah so that's that's pretty much it I
mean we're caught up on the Crowder
stuff alrighty and it's just so
again
[__] stupid bro he sucks I'm glad his
life's falling apart I hope it falls
apart more I hope he uh never finds love
again and
um well I hope he does find love again
but uh in the hands of those
he a lot of his problems with life would
be resolved if he would just kiss a man
he needs to kiss the man I think it goes
deeper than that yeah I I think you're
right unfortunately
let's talk to c-man let's talk to c-man
all right I I'm so sorry to keep him
waiting this long I'm gonna let him in
the room right now and we'll see what we
get
um we have a unicorn waiting in chat
this is c-man
do we have any fun can we ask him any
questions do we have any feet we have
like a whole thing in the dock
oh we've been ready for this have we
been ready well okay
okay I see him
see if we can get this down there he is
he's in the car he's in his natural
habitation
uh he's got to connect audio uh if you
can hear us see man you need to
click the audio button
I was driving home I work in Long Island
on Garden City Long Island I know I'm
driving home and now I'm in um Queens in
New York City by Peck Park in my
neighborhood I live in well Fresh
Meadows flushing but this is pet Park I
used to come up here a lot yeah you're
not driving right now are you
no but I was driving on hold while on my
lap but I'm gonna see him next to the
park Peck Park here in fashion managed
to go to when I was young again
let me see the feet yes what's up let me
see the feet
[Applause]
I am but I'll tell you it's it's the
weather's still 56 degrees here in New
York so
um it's pretty nice
um now I'm excited I was trying to get I
never used my phone before for any kind
of Zoom thing so it's kind of nice to
use a technology I'm really bad with
technology it really sucks you know
um and I think the problem with my
website a lot of stuff going on I'm
trying to um fix I have a lot of
problems with my site and people
couldn't get [__] it was just a mess and
didn't realize all this back end crap
it's been stressing me out and I have a
major video shoot I'm doing in Miami
Florida next week I'm flying down I'm
doing like an office setting tell us
tell me about the shoe what project are
you working on
oh I am doing a naked office scene where
we're doing a lot of foot worship a lot
of hot stuff I'm wearing a dull collar
I'm wear leather collar with a leash as
well which is hot I'm a kinky person
okay so hold on hold on so it's an
office scene
so do are you gonna have like a desk
with a computer are you gonna have like
a whole death situation
the person which is really nice okay um
I'm gonna be sitting at decimals and I
do it I'm also filming it which is good
um yeah it's gonna be exciting I'm I
have I have a column I'm going to wear a
collar which is really cool
um when you say color you made a caller
a collared shirt or just a call
oh you're going to be butt naked
butt naked at the whole point don't you
think we're gonna be 100 clothes and
then blah blah blah clothes coming in
it's a couple scenes and then we'll have
a little by little the clothes that come
off and make it really hot you know one
see man how is it possible that in 2013
you have such bad
uh internet speed on your phone 2000 uh
23. add 10. what kind of service do you
have
I have T-Mobile
I have prepaid T-Mobile
hmm
I'm also talking to my car that that
Bluetooth thing which is cool I never
had one of these things in my car here
so it's really wild to connect the phone
to that because I always had a car with
an older car you know that never had
this so it's quite wild so so I'm
interested in the scene so you're going
to be sitting butt naked but I actually
have a suggestion see man if the I'm not
gonna be I'm gonna be standing up I'm
gonna be filming but some scenes are
gonna be sitting down look I'm gonna be
like you know shorts like a regular
office like you're working in a real
company and then as we go by like
something's off shorts on them the slave
has to take the clothes off which is
pretty hot okay you know okay so you
start cleaning yeah
we start with clothes and then we get a
little bit it gets really hot and erotic
which is great the whole point when you
make adult videos it has to be
entertaining and hot it can't be just
dull everything has to be hot and erotic
to me if I can enter the mind of a foot
fetishist like yourself
I would imagine like you sitting there
in a full suit but no shoes and then
underneath and then underneath c-man
is the slave
yeah I just I like the two but I also
like them do other things so we're going
to really do a lot more than just the
feet so what other stuff what other
stuff will you guys graduate to I'm not
gonna mention it you know you know gay
men understand that there'll be a lot
more things that we're going to do
possibly because I was told that I I
they said I a lot of people wanted stuff
spicier which I said is a good way to
make it which is going to make it Spicer
which I don't have a lot of guys that
came on board Florida's a hot Market oh
by the way I'm sorry I forgot to say
hello Pennsylvania
I love Pennsylvania
I was gonna do a shoot in Philadelphia
because I had a big big um a lot of
people contact me in Philadelphia but I
was trying to get a one-day rental of an
office you know Florida's easier but
Pennsylvania it's difficult to try to
just get it off just rented somewhere
but I went down to Philly two weekends
in a row it's really cold
you said hello to uh Pennsylvania I
noticed on Reddit you're giving shout
outs to lots of States how important
Salt Lake City I
I like those other states and I want to
see how good they are it's not only
Pennsylvania because you know it's a lot
of Austin States out there that I've
been really interested lately in the
past and I did visit Portland a long
time ago I like Arizona because the
weather's nice and I really like the
whole outdoors and cactuses I like
Pennsylvania
kind of like like what we would have in
New York and New Jersey I mean Arizona
is going to be completely
what kind of responses are you expecting
from these posts because they have zero
comments usually like what's your ideal
response to a post well hello Phoenix
really what to say because I'm really
good when it comes to hard erotic stuff
but I guess Zona um I don't know I mean
like I said this I've been really just
and I really don't like politics so I
don't like either side of the spectrum
and I really don't want to get involved
well if I if I could
I would I would guess that liberals
would be more accepting of the foot
fetish
they are but I don't think
like sex doesn't matter who you are
you're going to do it I never heard of
someone sign a political party but I
never do anything sexual oh they're
definitely they're definitely more
accepting of gay sex
yeah
dude maybe you should drive somewhere
else she still likes you know other
things about gay sex what they see man
the connections real real [__] maybe
maybe try driving to a different
location with better reception
New York City is 25 miles per hour
um and they really get you photo
enforced and faster it's hold on it's
making less time absolutely drive safely
I'm driving safe as you see and this
[Music]
is crazy this is New York sorry this is
New York
I used to play ball there when I was a
little kid I used to play baseball
I don't know should we disconnect maybe
no
I'm good I'm good
no I can't I can see you Seaman it's
it's quite bad the reception all right
well I'm gonna move to another location
hold on
I should be having
now yeah
can you see me now yeah um maybe we
should reconnect should we try
reconnecting hold on hold on I'm gonna
go near Casino golf course because
there's a golf course here that's why we
got better connection
um and I'm right at
can you see the golf course can we talk
to something can you mute him uh no uh I
just wanna
let's let's you guys work it out behind
the scenes and then when he gets a good
connection let's let's bring him back on
how's that sound
sure and see you man whenever you find a
spot where it seems to be working better
just park again we can bring it back on
so yeah you guys work it out and then
when it's looking good then then we'll
we'll bring them back
uh but c-man is here and uh well he's
got a lot going on he says down in
Florida a big shoot coming up
uh we have feet slaves in the office
setting which sounds pretty hot pretty
sexy
pretty nice
I want to hear more about that
but in the meantime keep an eye on the
feed as soon as it looks like it is
stabilized I'll bring it back in
but in the meantime you know we had a
little game we wanted to play today
who has
the worst or best
Uber
ranking
and I and I bet you Stephen Crowder's
wife has got a really good Uber ranking
as
you know you don't want to mess around
when you're pregnant puncture
now Uber rates itself on a weird scale
because
correct me if I'm wrong you guys but
anything under a 4.5 is like monstrously
bad right
okay I heard I heard hold on Dan I'm
sensing defensiveness from you already
no I just want to point out that when
you first said that to me you said
anything under a 4.8 is monstrous well
like what well anything under 4.8 is bad
anything under 4.5 is like unfathom
unfathomable
and to the point where as I understand
drivers won't even pick you up if you
have a like a 4.5 cmax feed looks pretty
good yeah it looks pretty good I was
about to say here um
I just unmuted them see man can you hear
us you're looking it's looking a lot
better Wherever You Are
um can you hear me yeah yeah I think
we're back I think we're good can you
hear me now yeah so see man I want to
ask you
a better thing here I used to play golf
when I was younger it's much better so
c-man yes by the golf course yeah let me
ask you why did you reach out to us out
of the blue what is what is it that uh
you wanted to discuss with us
I was just seeing how you're doing
because I heard I had a lot of people
contact me on the side and tell me that
they want me back and they really liked
me and I I don't like to be right on
this show I mean I'd like to I need
something a better job than what I'm
doing now is you know I'm trying to get
you know besides doing those other stuff
I just really want to live life and go
different places but but yeah I'm just
really yeah trying to enjoy myself okay
well we're happy to hear from you too
you know the technology I found has been
really hurting a lot of my business
because I just cannot there's a lot of
back-end stuff and a lot of the site
just wasn't working in servers so now
I'm learning and I have someone helping
me with this which is good and I have a
shoot coming up and I have another shoot
plan a c-man I'm sorry the reception has
gone down again it's tough out there in
uh New York
we can hear you this is the video you're
just Frozen we see a we see a Frozen
Seamus yeah I'm sorry guys I want to
talk to sim as much as as you guys want
to hear from him but
uh this is kind of rough for the viewer
at the moment
so we can keep them on but I don't know
try to drive somewhere like else else
I I refuse to believe that he's on the
T-Mobile network this man is on like the
uh
he's on like the Z mobile network yeah
yeah maybe um here let me unmute him to
make sure he's hearing us see man it
might be a good idea to go home and try
it on your home internet because it
seems like the cell phone thing is is
struggling
yeah that'd be a good idea that's fine
no I think it's gonna work I think um
can you hear me can you hear me now yeah
see man how far are you from your house
uh 16 blocks okay go home and call us
yeah why don't we try from there
um all right hold on hold on all right
thank you c-man we'll uh we'll hear from
him soon
just trying to keep things go moving so
uh well actually Ela wanted to call him
too let's have let's talk to ELA then
she seems ready
I don't think she's ready oh she's not
ready I thought they messaged us a
message that they were on their way they
were just asking Okay cool so um so back
to the Uber rating oh cmad's giving it
away for free look at that
can you guys see that it's brighter than
that
holy [__] we're getting a free show
filmed on a calculator
I'll tell you what even in one pixel
this man is an Entertainer
entertain No Doubt
free show down there
um so
I do any of you guys uh maybe who are
Uber drivers is it true that if somebody
has like a 4.5 you're not gonna pick
them up because that's what I've heard
and the drivers are very picky oh my God
c-man is really oof given it
yeah what do you guys think about having
c-man to the live show and then bringing
up audience members to and he could
judge their feet I mean obviously they
volunteer
that could be a really fun segment
Interactive
oh man Jesus how is he recorded that
seems really unsafe
can you show that I mean this man is
giving like a POV driving I don't think
we
why
I'm not driving
I'll get a strike for him driving
what's happened
all right Dan says better cautious
better cautious yes but he's driving
very unsafe uh c-man please don't record
while you're driving we want you to be
safe there
thank you
um
just I I can't concentrate with you man
uh
on the screen there guys
oh my God wait it looks great now wait
do you see him like fix his hat guys
guys guys please just let him go home
yeah I think just let him go home this
is too difficult yeah thank you
Dan is keeping it on my monitor so I'm
just watching c-man he's showing his
feet he's driving he's holding the phone
showing the road while he's driving it's
like can't look away
well anyway I wanted to know who has the
worst and who has the best Uber ratings
we got everybody's everybody shared
their Uber ratings
was I don't know what they are who's the
gatekeeper who has them Ian Ian yeah
yeah was there any surprises um in the
score
I mean I guess you'll see I wasn't
surprised necessarily
was there any really low ratings
nothing mind-blowing you have some good
people in here oh [__] so this segment
sucks
so you got a diet on your hands well
especially since you just switch it up
instead 4.5 is the cutoff for being a
horrible rating because when we were
talking about it the other day
I was feeling very self-conscious
because you were like if it's I mean
anything below you've been like 4.95 you
are a piece of [__] I think that's true
frankly anything under 4.8 is uh let's
let's say that
so let's just reveal uh from lowest to
highest I think we can say 4.8 your
Stephen Crowder level psychopath uh it's
ranked ties from Los in the gallery
so let's start from the best and work
our way down
so Ian please reveal to us who has the
highest Uber rating score as a passenger
there's a gallery in there if you want
to pull it up oh I've got it here
all right
wow
the winner here has a perfect five star
rating well hold on some of us have the
same rating
okay chill out
take it easy
cam grants with a perfect five stars
359 rides cam how do you explain such a
high rating you're really good huh it's
I don't know sometimes the driver wants
to talk sometimes the driver doesn't
want to talk or just followed the
driver's lead and I always leave a tip
so as I understand it you're gonna get
rated low if you like
make them wait for a long time are you
doing Shenanigans like trying to stuff a
bunch of people into a car oh I'm never
about this oh you're annoying because
it's very nice
but 359 rides and not a single blemish
on your record fantastic thank you thank
you I would I would be lying my way to
pick you up any day thanks Cameron
uh Lena
also five stars go
there's I don't get to see the amount of
people so Kim's is from Lyft and this is
Uber Uber has less uh information you do
lift cam what's that about I do
whatever's cheaper okay you can get both
yeah I just figured because that had the
right amount and everything I'd submit
that one but oh it's smart you would
definitely want to check them both
okay what's your Uber rating then cam is
that on their end because I sent you in
both it's in there okay
um Olivia five stars
my goodness only 60 rides in eight years
yeah I use Lyft as an adult I used Uber
in high school okay but I do use lift
and I'm just the best passenger what can
I say wait these we're showing lift and
then uh Uber is that they what's they do
I just sent my lift because I've used
Uber in years
uh Abe who's Abe
that would be me because if I put a b
they're gonna call me AB so I just put
Abe
interesting pretty close yeah they won't
call you a b either
yeah
I mean I go by a whenever I like I place
a carryout order or something I don't
feel like I'm explaining how to spell a
b you'd be surprised how many people ask
yeah I'd love to know what the Crowder's
Uber rating is says Sarah I agree
completely
probably at a 4.7 or something psychotic
like that
Zach Bernstein five stars okay Ian
Slater five stars what is happening here
Samantha ooh with a brutal takedown 4.96
she's not even here to defend herself
doesn't look like male for Sam
okay hold on Cameron 4.92 so uh it's not
terrible trouble in Paradise perhaps
not terrible so this is this is mine and
gilas we share so we have the worst
rating so far by far
4.86
wow
Jenna dance word love
so this is why you're getting so
defensive I am baffled by this I have to
say baffled
I feel like I am the office no
no of course not no I can't think of
this I always tip fat I never make them
wait and I never say a [__] word
other than hey how's it going when I
first get in and thank you so much drive
safe have a good one when I leave that's
that's the extent and then I'm on my
phone
the whole ride that's the problem
because I think I'm not friendly like
they want me to talk Zach thinks you
need to make their their day better you
need to make and there's one question I
don't always I always say this and
there's like a little voice in my head
like don't say it don't say it don't say
it how long you've been doing Uber for
oh God that's nice so annoying like how
is that not annoying a five-star rating
Dan people want to talk and the other
factor is obviously since the pandemic I
always wear a mask too so it's like I'm
like what am I doing wrong I don't make
them wait a tip I don't bother question
man I have to say you probably have you
this is hundreds of rides probably I
have which I I might have the most Uber
rides which means Dan that this is a
significant amount of people not I I
know I I don't know I don't have any
justification
because let's say you have 500 rides
you would need like 20 or plus one star
ratings to move it down a bunch
I don't know
um
I have no explanation I'm genuinely bad
you're almost a 4.8
wow ask them how their day is going
does anyone else use your Uber no that's
what I'm gonna say have you booked for a
guests Maybe
actually yes but that'd be awesome Bert
Kreischer just like pissing them off
when we picked up the ride firm but you
use use your personal use ours uh I
think I did use my personal and just
because you can have multiple cards in
there
you think the guests [__] me that's
that actually seems more likely than
anything you know they're Divas driving
angry I remember the first time we
called it a guest I knew about that at
all it was Bert Kreischer yeah and I
didn't know what I was doing I sent him
a a normal Uber not like the Uber Uber
blocker which we do now the Uber black
yeah and he was like he was like pit or
no he wasn't pissed but he's like what
the f like he was kind of shocked he you
know he's Burt Chrysler he's famous he's
like some random like dude who didn't
speak English and like a tiny stinky car
came to get him and uh he's a celebrity
so he had a little bit of a diva moment
drive angry and perhaps thanked your
rating Ben fascinating okay that gives
me at least something even if that's not
true that at least allows my mind to
latch onto something because I was I was
feeling very lost I was feeling hurt I
was feeling lost I didn't understand
what I was doing wrong this will give
you some Solace this gives me at least
some sort of like plausible explanation
I felt worthless yeah Janet people ask
me what's Jenna that's just a like
pseudonym so that people don't recognize
her name yeah people don't know that
that it's Ela when she ordered stuff or
calls it right
um
that name scares me still to this day
which one
Jenna why
the incident we talked about the other
week Jenna
what's happening what the [__] are you
talking about love
wait wait no one remembers it's not
about the genocide he supports genocide
joke
oh genocide oh
you got trolled by Jenna
suddenly ah Jenna's side right
[Music]
well there it is uh Dan apparently is
just a there's no nightmare I guess I'm
playing for Chrysler he [__] me
forever and all the other guests that we
yeah I mean I'm trying to think like we
did that we've done that for a lot of
guests
who do you think
I mean I guess we know that Bert had
like a it was all about Diva so and he
did twice it was all him yeah
uh by the way a friend of um
someone posted our subreddit an old
friend of Aiden Ross wait was this an
original post
it looks like it was holy [__] okay so
we have kind of a breaking well it's not
that breaking but here's a video he says
I was Aiden Ross friend in high school
I'm disappointed to hear all the
horrible things he's been doing recently
it's sad to see him change so
drastically especially since he was the
sweetest kid in high school we used to
watch old H3 videos together even in
class oh that hurts
is that why he wants my validation so
bad that's what I was thinking yeah I
mean that's why I kept asking if you
hate him
here he is he looks so young man little
Aiden Ross
it's sweet this is like uh get away from
me you're making me nervous ah I feel
like I'm watching
are you glancing at the button I was
what are you cooking what are you
cooking maybe I just didn't do it I just
saw your eyes
you're doing hand warm-ups to hit it too
yeah exactly maybe I just shouldn't I
shouldn't speak if I speak I'll be in
big trouble
uh so but here he is yeah
in big trouble and I don't want to be in
big trouble there it is uh Aiden I don't
know how you became
there was a path for you
it's just a fact in my opinion you could
have been one of the good ones but one
of our last our last Aiden update was
that he admitted to uh having like a
relapse and saying all that uh
recent stuff he's been doing was as a
result of that so I don't know maybe
there's still a path path to the light
for him is he off the internet love
maybe you know since he put out that
I've relapsed well I haven't heard
anything since then
oh he's still streaming yeah he's still
on he was talking [__] about uh I show
speed's new song that came out the other
day
all right thank you
yeah
Cam and I watched it yesterday
I thought I think I showed speed as
potential
and like the music I don't know he had
like a good energy yeah I wish I could
watch it but I probably not a good idea
probably get claimed yeah
um
also in other news
Andrew Tate
is looking probably as bad as Steven's
feeling look at this [__] picture
dude this man is
he posted devastated do we have all of
the tweets because he deleted it all oh
he did yeah no he he nuked everything
because everybody was clowning on him so
hard beta yeah so if you scroll down
there's there's screen capture the
videos the tweets are
this has been such
there's been a lot of W's this week
that's all I'm saying this is the
universe this was so good
I mean it really look under Tate's body
is falling apart Crowder's wife left him
Tucker got fired it's just like the the
W's keep coming that's true let's get
some crab walks going
he said he wrote a poem about it face
swollen blood pressure is through the
roof Skin's on fire hard to breathe some
sort of severe reaction or poison
only had coffee and water so far today
all appeared in the last five minutes
eyes almost shut
Gathering Chi
yeah he erased it he's fine he's like I
just see you're just being a baby
he's got a headache
I swear to God man this is like
it doesn't work either
it's giving a Saddam and a hole I know I
bring that up a lot no but this one
you're right yeah it's giving
saddamental definitely here let's pull
up the picture
[Music]
love that he's doing so good though
you know
so here's Saddam in the hole or just
post hole
just post hole yes this is post hole
that's post hole
that particular that looks really
similar yeah
so um
let's keep going but yeah I'm feeling
that
um
God damn it it's a keyboard
here he's posting again kind of like uh
if they kill me I love you all
bro the focal point of this is literally
your juicy thighs yeah these these are
all from the video like come on dude
he just took a Benadryl and was okay
that's it that's what happened yeah
that's they're trying to kill me yeah
really it was just a cat
yeah you sound like a little bit of a
beta
uh oh my that doesn't even look that bad
like it doesn't
you're talking about if they kill you oh
didn't you say you have a rash all over
your body today
if they kill me can you imagine how
dramatic if I was on Twitter yo I think
someone's trying to kill me
yeah
amazing it's barely perceived
perceptible it's like okay you at you
ate a peanut or peanut grazed on your
skin right
oh um
c-man has rejoined the lobby on a
different account I suspect that he's
home do you want to try look at this
look at this what the [__] even is this
hmm
yeah the Sun from being yeah it just
looks sunburned slightly
what a [__] baby
here okay so that at least it's here a
little bit uh noticeable
okay yeah see the rash there
yeah they're trying to kill him
baby time I'm being murdered
help I'm being murdered
people get rashes man you know
I hate to break it to you but and then
he erased them all I guess he said if I
tell if I tell the truth they'll put me
in jail he said and then he said head to
delete
whatever but
red
you know how Andrew Tate's been plotting
to escape the country
this hole is big enough for the two of
them
worked out real good
all right let's try c-man one more time
all right one more time from the top
ladies and gents
he won the only
man okay I see it I see he's at home I'm
here now yes I'm home
that's what I'm talking yeah much better
well
so see man tell me um
I want to know more about the shoot
you're planning so so how many guys are
going to be involved in it
well basically it's going to be about
six guys pretty much
um oh the illusion I think I got you
back on there again yeah it's about six
guys how many slaves
well we're gonna play different roles
like I'll be Master Ensley I want guys
to be versatile because I don't really
want it to be all one way because it
looks really silly I mean some guys
prefer to do more than others but I want
to do variety because every shoot we're
gonna have you know different positions
and everything too so it'll be kind of
nice and do you prefer to be the master
or the slave I like both I mean I love
being a dirty little slave I like just
being like tied up in all the hot erotic
stuff I'm very kinky so what do you like
people to do to you when you're tied up
because I've never that I'm not gonna
discuss not in front of this I mean
that's just something but
um a gentleman never But but so all the
good stuff I'm assuming
um yeah all the good stuff I mean
there's some things there's some things
you know that
I won't get into but there are some
things that I that I really love to do
like I just like I said having a collar
on with a little leash is pretty hot
I've always thought about that and I've
always wanted to have a collar on which
is nice and then you know be kind of
cool so we're gonna get shirts and say
slave on it like red shirts because I'm
gonna say slave on it which is pretty
cool and I'm gonna get my new sock line
I'm trying to create where it says um
serve the master so when the guy's
worshiping the feed pretty hot because I
try to do obey the master I did that a
long time ago I did like one sock and I
had it pressed on and apparently a baby
company came after me I don't know why I
didn't steal their stuff I said obey the
Master's not something you know big
company they said you better stop or
we're going to press charges I'm like
what [__] is it possible someone was
trolling you
no I was in Australia when I tried the
sock and I made it in Australia and
apparently they sent me a letter in
Australia which is so weird so they're
like baby socks in Australia that says
obey the master
no there wasn't baby socks I tried one
or two pairs of socks I threw them in
the garbage it was pretty hot I actually
got a big I got people tell me it was
amazing they wanted they're like this is
great let's let's get it out there and I
someone saw my video of me you know
having this hot erotic video with obey
the master and Obey company said when
they wrote a letter got a law firm after
me so I stopped they said you better
stop showing these socks and better
dismantling your videos but you were
wearing their socks no it was my socks
the plain white socks I got from
Australia Kmart and I went to a person
to press it on you know I could press a
baseball jersey with the letters on it
and I figured it'd be kind of great to
do a video I think okay so obey the
brand Sawyer yes the obey company saw my
thing on my YouTube channel and I was in
Australia and that's they try to show
like yeah they would this is what goes
on you know I mean it's crazy how do you
suppose one of them I guess someone over
there is a fan though they're behind the
paywall right no I just think maybe you
know I think a lot of corporations are
are using YouTube to like go out after
people maybe divide by by you know
people using their brands without you
know getting aware getting awareness or
without getting permission to get
awareness for their brand because you
know I when I had to when I was a
business major I um studied a lot of
that stuff and you can't just Market
someone's product without them knowing
about it unless they approve I mean
everybody wants publicity but
look what happened with the Liam the
idiot look at me tried to do something
with me that piece of [__] excuse my
language oh I forgot about that man well
he was a big piece of [__] yeah that was
that was a big yeah I've totally forgot
about the whole Genesis
yeah I don't want to think about that
anymore but yeah so see man have you had
any good encounters like how's your love
life going I'm just curious as a passion
that I'm talking about I don't talk
about that um pretty much I'm really not
ready to date yet I mean I'm trying to
in some ways to get back out there again
but I'm just focusing on trying to grow
my brand grow my business really get get
more
um get more known and I'm actually
getting a lot of awareness now because
I've been doing a lot of um on Reddit
and other places as well which is great
and I know that I've had some setbacks
because you're trying to do adult videos
and it's gonna be hard to get your name
out there because people have to trust
how you are there's like nine or ten
other big
Studios or porn places that are well
known and you know they got most of the
traffic in most of the market so what is
your what is your competitive Advantage
do you think that we're going to be able
to get you on top of these big studios
well because my thing is I'm just
focusing on one fetish a lot of adults
I'm doing doing a little other stuff but
I'm not going to be doing I mean if they
want to do porn stuff they can in the
videos I'm just not selling it as a
major product because it's too much of
it like I tell people there's a lot of
guys with foot fetish it but they tell
me I want to do more I want to do more
yes I love feet but I really want to and
other things and I'm like I don't want
to do that because my problem is there's
so much out there that is if you
specialize in your fetish but do most of
your fetish you will make more money
because you'll see man is the foot
enough for you is that enough to satisfy
yourself
I do like everything else of course I go
further absolutely you can't just stay
with one thing and any fetish you have
you just can't but I want to do more of
this because this is like you know
basically like I say the the appetizer
before them so do you do you usually and
I'm sorry this is vulgar but I uh just I
need confirmation so do you usually
finish on your partner's feet or how
does that work
well I can't really say
um I think it depends because if we're
finishing at that moment yeah I mean
usually I'll do the food first and all
this stuff but I guess I could finish on
their feet they finish on my feet okay I
mean that's a good idea
what you finish on each other's feet and
then do you go foot to foot after that
it's really hard to say it just depends
on the mood and the time I mean any
sexual thing you do it depends on the
mood with the person the timing depends
if you want to do stuff I mean like I
said the price I've done a lot with many
guys but there's some guys where it just
didn't do it for me you know they might
have had nice feet but they didn't have
nice other things so they didn't have a
good personality or they have a very few
questions here dull and boring and I
just was not turned off you seem real
kinky and you're so proud of the foot
thing has have you ever hooked up with
someone where you're like this guy is
too kinky for me I gotta Bail no I mean
years ago I would say I wasn't as kinky
as I was I mean feat's only a portion of
kinkiness there's millions of other
kinky stuff I mean there's some things I
won't do but I think it's great to be
kinky and I think more people need to
because kinkiness is is a really
important healthy part of life
your whole [__] life what's that
what's the craziest hookup you've had
anything come to mind I think when I
think when somebody wanted to put food
in my ass and okay that's pretty crazy
it was really weird like I wouldn't I
wouldn't I don't like anything in my ass
but not only that is I don't like
anybody going near my butt and I think
it's horrible I mean there are a lot of
gay guys that want to do a lot of ass
stuff but some guy wanted to put
strawberries pineapples and other stuff
in my ass and I'm like bro that [__]
doesn't work with me okay so it's not
even fruit in my ass so I don't want
anything in mind what's the logistics of
that because I would imagine it would be
quite
a tight space for a fruit it would be a
mess right you wouldn't be able to get
along the strawberry
I mean I don't know I'm not into the
whole place right I'm not into that I
mean if a guy if a guy wants to play
with my butt I'll let him try but one
person did it was a bit odd for me it's
not something I really like per se and I
tell people that look I mean this I
don't mind doing a lot of kinky stuff
wild and crazy I mean I've licked a guy
from head to toe my tongue when he put
Hershey syrup on his body and also
coconut water that was fine I've done a
lot of crazy I've done a lot of great
stuff so so was the idea that you would
shove a strawberry up there and then he
would eat it out it was that the theory
I don't know it never happened I was
just so turned off I'm like you know see
I don't want to talk to you no more
Connie's like oh you're an ass so your
dick you're typical [__] New York I'm
like bro get the [__] up did you leave
well hold on did that ruin the moment
when he requested the fruit in the ass
yeah I think it kind of did it was so
strange to me because I didn't know if
anybody asked that request because the
guy goes you have a really nice ass as
well thank you because I mean I am a
good looking guy I'm not of course yeah
yeah of course I'm really good looking
yeah cool I would never ever obviously
100 but the point was you know just the
whole butt thing just kind of got me off
turned off I'm like I'm gonna go now and
get pizza oh so you guys did you guys
didn't end up hooking up
well the foot thing was good because the
thing was was ironic because he never he
wanted to get into feet his whole life I
think was burning to do something really
different and I was trying to show him
and he got really hot and wild and we
really had a good moment together and I
was really excited because it seemed
like a nice guy he was a bit Bell and
boring like he did wasn't adventurous
like I like outdoors and Hiking he just
seemed to be like a home person and go
to bars and drink and get drunk your
whole life and you know kill his liver
you know I'm a health nut I try not to
do that I also stopped drinking but I
remember when he said to me you know
you're a really nice guy you're sweet I
love your you know personality you're
sorry interesting you're fun to be with
you know really nice guy but and I was
just like I'm sorry I was just you know
when you're so turned on when you hit
somebody you just want to have fun and
do it but that moment really killed me
okay you know it was the point where I
couldn't do this so there's some things
I don't do like I said I'm a very kinky
person like I will just like I said I
will do [__] in cars I will do stuff in
bushes
I mean a strawberry I gotta say a
strawberry asses it's kinky but it's
kicky but probably not crazy but I mean
okay I have a question I have a question
yes do you ever the men you hook up with
are they ever married
no I don't want to [__] with straight
people they're [__] in the head oh you
don't you don't mess with you don't
sorry no offense but straight people are
really screwed in the head because they
sit there and cry because they got they
got turned down by a girl or they want
emotional support and they come to a gay
man they want to play around some gay
men's love some gay men love that but I
try to stay away from Married Men
because they are trouble and I had a
friend in Florida years ago who swore to
God they're the best people to date me
had the secret relationship behind the
scenes and it really [__] his head up
and
it really it screwed up because first of
all if you're really straight you
wouldn't sleep with a man so a lot of
these straight guys though I'm [__]
straight I'm [__] straight I'm sick
of hearing that when they're out
somewhere or they want to meet somebody
they want to hook up with a guy that's
the first thing you say you know it's a
big turn off it's disgusting if you're
uncomfortable with your sexuality go
somewhere else I mean but the point is
you come to me I didn't come to you I
didn't reach out to your ass free but
don't reach out to me okay and that's
one thing that's my biggest pet pee my
freaking hate I'm straight guys contact
number I don't want to touch you you you
got a wife if your wife is not King he
doesn't find you attractive then find
another wife don't come to [__] me
yeah
[Applause]
Charles you hear that I'm sick with
these [__] straight guys who just
come here trying to dominate the gay
community and they pretend to be gay
it's [__] insulting when somebody
pretend to be gay first of all
absolutely disgusting and rude and
showed their character like they think
that being gay is just some joke or
something wow you know good for you you
know what I mean being gay is a real
freaking thing so yeah that's a good
Insight I appreciate that yeah it's nice
no I'm just saying this I'm just I'm
just so tired of just the [__]
that's out there and it's really driving
me crazy because my point is you know
we're gay men we want to be around our
own Brothers I mean there's bisexual men
out there I don't mind if you're
bisexual that I respect because you like
bolts actually turned on but when you
come and tell me you're a married guy
you want you want to hang out with the
Bros a different story but then you want
to start doing sexual stuff and then you
get mad when you do sexual stuff or
something and can't handle and then
whatever it's like you know if you have
feelings for a man then say it but don't
sit there and say every five minutes
have you ever had a relationship like
that
I had well this was an interesting story
years ago in Florida in 2006 I lived in
St Petersburg Tampa Bay and I remember I
was next door to this really
hot guy I mean guy was really wild
um and I would you know I would come in
and it turned out I don't know I guess
he might have been gay I don't freaking
though he could have been whatever you
know people exploring whatever and he
tells me because he'll meet me one day
it's the weirdest thing in the world you
know hey what's up you know you know I
was asking is the area good you know I
want to make sure my car's you know
unlocked I leave my doors on good
everything's okay because everything
goes to me oh by the way I'm straight
like what the [__] does that mean when
you first meet somebody yeah and it was
so weird and then he's like we're
hanging out as we get to know each other
he was telling me well
um I kind of want to do this with a guy
and one day we got drunk together and
just when I was drinking a lot and he
was just sitting there telling me he
would fantasize about being a slave to
this guy who's really getting dirty and
he said you know obviously doesn't talk
about this in front of girls you never
none of the girls knew about it and he
wanted to deal with me and back then I
guess I wasn't as kinky I was just me
anymore into the feed stuff but I wasn't
really into the whole other stuff back
in 06 so you know I said well okay let's
meet up and then when I went to see him
he was okay for the first 40 minutes
afterwards he kept saying but you know
I'm straight but I'm straight
no you're not straight it's like you
were straight you wouldn't even you
wouldn't even be in the room with me bro
so let me ask you this what was the
gayest thing he did while he was there
with you
you look at my armpits which is a bit
weird he licked your armpits yeah
because I guess the girl's thing that's
what that's that's pretty good
interesting that's pretty good it's not
too bad because I mean I've done a lot
of things with guys I've done it before
but you know I mean I guess he wanted to
try something other than you know play
with your penis because you know what
men we know how to play with a penis but
the thing is
um he just wanted to do an armpit I
guess he was just trying to do something
because I want to try different things
I'm like well go ahead and I'm like okay
it's it felt okay but it wasn't like the
super biggest turn on I'm sitting there
going okay how are you gonna please me
you know obviously straight guys he's
like I'm really new to this can you show
me some pointers I'm like I I you know I
don't know what to say to this person
we're so strange and I'm like you know
what kind of pointers do you want you
know what I mean like so did either of
you guys finish during the act or was it
just kind of an awkward he had really
hot feet I mean I told him I jerked off
on his feet we took a ride together
well he wanted to go to 7-Eleven he
didn't care about putting shoes on so
and then I jerked off in his car and he
was like that was really hot oh he said
jerking off in the car was really hot
and I jumped off on the steering wheel
and all the coming around the steering
wheel
you came on his steering wheel and I
made him lick it off
okay so you guys are driving to a
convenience store you come on a steering
wheel and he lit is he licking it off
while he's driving or when he's slightly
little by little like like basic like
little baby licks I'm like Gonna Be A
Man About It you know [__] [__] you know
don't be a little pants
did he say I'm straight during any of
that no it was just his mine was I think
he's loosening up more with me because I
think a lot of guys I guess that are
coming out with their sexuality I guess
little by little I guess they're afraid
and denial this is the problem I'm
seeing a lot more now because even with
this video shoot I have now I make sure
it's only gay guys because they don't
want to ruin the moment I you know for
the safety also we don't know who these
people are they could come and kill us
so you got to be very careful of it you
know Miami's a pretty open-minded City
but still Florida what's going on right
now in the State of Florida but a lot of
things you know you really need to be
careful right you know you know so and
he's like you know I made sure you know
you can't really prove someone's gay or
straight on the phone you know I mean
they're saying that I want to do this
I'm really turned on but you know you
should as a as a test for entry make
them lick your semen off a steering
wheel
when was joking with that much I guess I
have to be in in a really turned on mood
um but we're gonna I'm gonna try to do a
lot more hot things there but there are
we have auditions in the morning but I
want to ask more about the your
rendezvous with this straight guy
so you did the whole steering wheel
thing and then what did you guys where'd
you guys go after that you go back to
your apartment or did you part ways they
end up next door so I went back to my my
rooms I remember I had to work early
that day and I think he did like TR like
he did construction or outdoor stuff and
he had to go to work up next morning and
after that was really weird because we
really didn't weren't as social anymore
huh I guess maybe he was kind of
embarrassed he was always out and I try
to say hi to him as a friendly neighbor
oh St Petersburg Florida you know it's
warm out people outside everywhere so
you know you feel kind of like used uh
after the first time and then he didn't
want anything I don't mind fooling
around people once or twice I don't mind
you know I don't like the word one night
stands I mean I don't care I've had a
lot of them I don't mind if sometimes
because sometimes that's how you get to
know people sometimes in a one-night
stand and they want to come back if
you're really good or so or sometimes
you know it's not only just the sex I
want to get to know people I usually
hang out people get to know them see how
they are but I just hate when people are
just faking who they are or what they
like they should there and that has to
wait about eight months to tell you with
somebody it's like and I give up you
know if you can't even be fun and erotic
you know when I'm with you or you're
maybe just not normally erotic and you
want to pretend to be kinky just because
you want to feel you know open mode can
I ask you this yeah where's the craziest
place you've had sex because the
steering wheel come thing you mentioned
pretty casually and that was a surprise
to me I have to say
I guess that's not really wild and crazy
it's really hard to say
um
I almost I well I came close to coming
in a public supermarket in Florida paper
towel paper towel I'm coming out
touching myself now hold on hold on hold
on come was dripping down my leg for
intensiveness Christ that is I'm a ton I
got a big dick yeah he's Italian how big
are we talking see man
I don't I don't that's something I
really can't discuss you just said you
agree you got a big one well it's more
than nine or less than Twelve so you
figure oh my goodness more than nine and
less than 12. well why don't you give us
so you'll give us a range but you won't
give us the exact measurement
because sometimes it's not always always
right away that big you don't want to
give us
no I was told normally it's around a 10
10 and a half when I'm really hard but
when I'm really super targeted 20 I
could hit 11 because I pushed it up to
my belly button once I was in pain and
my reaction was so hard like I don't
always get like that but sometimes I'm
really turned on you know you haven't
had it in a while you're just in the
mood sometimes you're in a really
interesting mood that you really need to
be super sexed up and I pushed myself
through one day I swear to God I was in
pain like I thought I had chest pain so
I'm gonna go what's happening to me like
I was so tired not enough blood all the
blood went to your [__] I don't know but
and this one guy told me you're probably
at 11 I said you've got to be kidding me
but see man I'm bigger than that if
you're that stacked it seems like you
would have a pretty promising career in
uh adult entertainment
yeah I mean I I guess I just I don't
want to go too much into the porn like I
said I'll do some of it I just don't
want to focus because the problem is
there's so much of it out there and what
gets me about the point is you know I
don't mind porn I like it but it's just
dull it's the same old stuff you know
fetishes are really the way to go
because fetish like I said people it's a
way of life you could do more you could
be more real with a fetish than opposed
to more porn let me ask you this also a
lot of porn places it looks so fake I
tell people to be real in the video do
what you really love let it come out
that's what makes things exciting any
director would understand that because
you're really doing your heart some of
the [__] you see out there people say I
wish I could have done this in the video
it's like an artist in a sense well yeah
but I was talking to a porn star once to
get some advice about you know the
business and stuff and he said to me you
know the heart's the hardest thing in
the world because a lot of guys go in
the video they want to do so much and it
turned on but the [__] director is
either boring and dull and so that has
to be my way and I'm like why don't you
fight the [__] dude you're the
one acting you're making my so that's
why I give my guys a chance to do what
they want to do although we're not going
too much into it because we're only
focusing on the feet which is the most
important so they can't do everything
but I like the creative uh Freedom you
get you have to be creative actor you
have to be but see man I want to go back
to the grocery store
that was a long time ago in the
supermarket called Publix in Florida
right and it was really cool because
um I was turned on because I saw these
guys going Barefoot to the store and I
was just walked in raining one day
because I was going to the beach I was
going somewhere else and I was just
super turned on that day and I'm going
to get something and I hope I'm not
going on paper towel aisle and I saw
these two guys had really nice feet
because I was looking down my camera I
didn't really look at their face I was
looking at my phone because back then
they had those little I had a flip phone
you know a little were you recording
their feet see man no I was just looking
at a text message okay and I said these
stupid I was so turned on so I started
just I could come I could come and I'll
touch on myself a little much so it
comes like jumping down my shorts on
this I had to cover myself it was really
crazy because I was almost sticking out
of my shorts that's how big I was
because it was so big it just pops up my
shorts were kind of short but not that
short but I was so turned on so I kind
of hide myself and I almost want to rip
the paper towel open and cover it but
that's where I walked around and paid my
thing on myself so these guys had such
hot feet that you just busted
and you know it's all year round
yeah I was just so turned on just that
that day for some reason I was just so
turned on I can't explain you know some
days you'd be more turned on than you
really are other days you busted in your
pants so what did you do how did you
conceal that
I just passed there was a little bit of
a stain on as a wedding base you said it
was dripping down your leg kind of I had
to rub my leg a little bit but it wasn't
much it wasn't a lot
it wasn't like the Mississippi River
gushing going until it wasn't like that
I couldn't get that though I could
become the professor if I had to it was
my little joke
um you know
that's why I always tell guys to spell
m-i-s-s-i-p-p-i when I'm ready to come
because let me tell you if you can spell
it out and then hit the I and you're
done okay
um
gotta be creative you know
but anyway because I love your stories
see man I love your stories you know uh
I love your experiences I want you to
share your experiences and your stories
with them well because the thing is I
think a lot of people are just so afraid
to have fun I think people are just so
dull like I see it even here in New York
it's like I meet people and they're just
like everyone's so just oppressed or
just scared to just get out and live
life it's like they're so hustle bustle
you talk to them they're like afraid of
everything I mean it's like you know
what the [__] are we living in North
Korea come on grow up and let's have fun
let's do the club and start coming on
Wheels I'm Life's too short
I want more stories give me give me your
give me some what's some of your
favorite all-time hits I can't get
enough of it
okay I have to think about it um okay I
wasn't an airplane once an airplane one
which was good I suppose a hot flight I
was going to um Germany in 2003 because
I was studying abroad for one year in
Germany right so I was on a plane I was
on um
I think I forgot what I think what
family Airline was a big wide body and
it was only six and a half hour for us 8
30 at night we land about 6 a.m and I
was sitting you know you know I was in
the back of the plane back then you
could lay across the three rows you know
they weren't charging you so and the
flight center was sitting back up it was
feet up and he had black socks oh yeah I
almost blew it and I was very young then
too back in 2003.
um and I was so turned on so I was I had
something happened I woke up I was like
the middle of the night it was dark I
thought they'll see the airplane and I
think they were serving food
I was laying sideways and they said to
me we're serving meals you want to eat
or should I come back and I'm looking I
was looking straight down
um because he was behind me he was in a
soft foot and then I guess he went to
get ready to to do the cabin and I guess
he came back obviously had to put shoes
back on but he was behind me because he
asked me they told people to get people
up because I didn't want to bother them
and I was hungry I think it was like a
rice and a steak meals back then you had
nice meals and and coach and it was
really hot and um I went to the bathroom
and jerked off
and I came on came all over the the the
Little Kitchen little uh sink thing and
I'll clean it up that is [__] that's
DC man did you clean it up at least of
course I did I'm not gonna leave my my
it's a gentleman of course but you
[__] all over the little [__] yeah
my jizz anywhere I always could not you
know I try to be here why should I leave
this unless I'm in a bath house and I
let the person you know you know leave
some of the little zip a little a little
um what they call Ziploc bag to bring
home and play with I don't know [__]
I had somebody do that request me which
was weird people at a bath house have
you come into a Ziploc bag once in
Australia yeah because it's really weird
in Australia I guess the guy wanted to
see a hot American [__] um he was an
Asian guy but it was really weird I
don't you know I'm not really it's weird
he was also in the 65 70 I'm not really
turned on by old men but he was I was
just turned on the hot tub and I went to
the you know that really really hot
sauna room it's really hard to jerk off
because it's so hot you feel like you're
dying you feel like you're having a
heart attack to even breathe and those
freaking things my dick was really big
as usual but and it was kind of getting
soft because the problem was it was too
damn [__] hot I nearly wanted to die
so I walked out and started freezing all
of a sudden so I went into the water
into the shower and I'm walking around
you know the bath house you know it's
just different little rooms a big TV
screen and and basically it was a um
trying to think there was I was gonna
took my towel off and I was really up
and all these creepy old men were like
trying to chase me and I'm thinking
myself well I mean but men are creepy
the old men like 65 and over I'm not
into that I mean I know that they want
to feel loved in their old age but you
know I'm not old and I don't really want
to play with an old person that that
just was like six seven years ago so I
was you know in my early 40s but still I
didn't really want so where does the
Ziploc bag come in
this Asian guy came up to me and said to
me you know you have a really nice
penis I'm like well thank you he's like
can I play with it I'm like we're in a
bath house of course you could I mean
I'm open free reign I'll tie myself to
the wall I don't care I like awesome I'm
I'm fine I like to have fun I gotta say
man
you go into these doors you gotta stand
you go in these dark rooms you know the
people are touching people you don't
even know what the person looks like so
you're people you'd have to expect that
when you go into these sex places well
it's nice that he asked though right
well it was really weird because also
was in Australia and Australia it's a
bit different culture like even though
people are not like America though but
they're just like they they kind of
don't they kind of will go near you but
they kind of will touch us a bit weird
to come up to me asking me can I have
you come to bring home with him like I
was weird
the guy goes his lock comes back because
I'm a little bag can you come in I'm
like that was really weird I'm like
that's the strangest thing someone ever
told me and I looked at this guy like is
he really weird or is he really strange
or maybe I'm just I'm just gonna walk
away from her it's a bit odd then I saw
him in this dark room because I was
laying down in this little in this
little Contraption where you're strapped
down there's like a big chain and my
legs are up in the air I'm like Oh my
handsome bath house it's not [__] bad
that was crazy wait okay okay it's like
a sex chamber okay there's a sex chamber
so hold on hold on I have a lot I have a
lot of questions but let's not let's not
lose the thread
did you come in the bag
I kind of no I came myself and then when
I took my fingers and part of my head
and I just put it on the bed and let go
I didn't really come hard I really
couldn't come that that far I was kind
of turned on but at that moment also I
kind of couldn't shoot that much so I
just can't because I probably had
finished like 20 times already that day
I probably was because when you come two
or three times hard to to get more it's
hard to shoot out further so you did
your best for him but you were running
on low
yeah but when you get older it's not
like you know you can shoot high as a
kite you understand that right of course
so but the thing is but the thing also
is so I was in this little thing with it
with a little change you know it was
kind of like a sex thing and I mean I
was just laying there you kind of turned
guys on when you they walked by and they
peek in and I was also moaning I was
like I like to do some money took you
know I mean the door is locked they
can't really see them they think you're
with somebody in the broom started
moaning like I was having sex all these
people started knocking into like 100
people wanted to break the door down
thinking what am I doing so I'm going
I'm really getting really into the
moaning it was pretty hot you know so
and I'm kind of trying to finger myself
a bit so I can make it sound good
um and that you know and I was doing
well it's a guy opened the door
it comes in he starts trying to finger
me and I'm like this is weird I don't
want your finger me I Don't Go Near in
my ass just like off the chain I find it
interesting you describe anything that
happens in there as weird
no it's not weird just I know this stuff
is expected I mean the bath house
anything goes there's so many things you
would imagine going on but I meant it
was odd that he just came in put his
finger in my ass oh he just went right
now usually they just touched the penis
first or they'll rub your body
dinner at least yeah well the thing was
I was I was playing with myself a bit
just to kind of turn people on to see
who's going to come in the room because
that's kind of the things to get people
in okay and it was this really old
creepy guy and I don't want to I don't
want to offend anybody 65 and over but
I'm sorry you know I know you lived your
life you're probably on your way out I
hate to say that but you know I I don't
I don't want a seven it's as gross I've
never comment 770 I don't want to fool
around the world you know I know I'll be
70.
the old you know came in straight to fit
and finger to the box like apparently
what happened was what I found out was
he was fingering like 15 people in the
Next Room before
and they were just in the ass and I'm
like you know I'm not I mean I I think
of myself a little bit because it's kind
of like around the edge a little bit to
turn on and I I play with my balls a
little bit which kind of turns on
because you get really you know kind of
building up there because you know it's
that spot where you start then you're
gonna explode but the point was he
wanted to go in further I'm like dude
not go in further I don't like this you
kind of her up and just uh well I was
just laying with my legs up in the air
and I was just like you know you could
rub my legs whatever you want hope you
can play with my feet I mean at least if
you're old man I mean I don't mind if
you licking my feet but I just didn't
want you want to have sex with me and
I'm like you know I don't want to have
sex with you I'm not really turned down
I I don't I'm not totally familiar with
this concept of the bath house
so it's like because people are not
familiar with it because it's basically
what gay guys do it's anything goes in a
bath house and they could have his crazy
wild sex you want bathhouse is really
awesome so it's a man is a place for gay
men to come and just a lot of straight
men a lot of married men couldn't
believe it or not they don't they don't
talk about it they don't have a lot of
married men
okay a lot of married men come too now
is this how do you know how do you know
which bath house to go to are they all
like this well I don't know because the
glottom of closed down uh I know there's
two or three in Tampa Florida that were
good there was one I think um
I can't remember where else I went to
one a long time ago in Phoenix Arizona
that was in 2008 was good
um and quite a few in Australia the ones
in New York don't really how do you find
the ones that are like you can have sex
with everyone like how do you because
every bath house you pretty much have
sex every bath house pretty much I mean
some of them some of them but because
they're private they're private friends
hold on hold on hold on hold on
if I look up Bath House la
because here I see I see Spa does that
count as a bath house I don't know I
don't know what's I don't know it's not
a spot I know it's a men's gay men's
bath house but think about it is a lot
of it's like it looks it's like a
hallway and there's like a little little
small rooms and they're dark some of
them have beds in them some have like
little little like benches and they'll
have obviously condoms and other stuff
and you know you can have sex there but
some people do it in the main where
there's a TV because you could sit naked
watching TV someone have a little snack
machine I gotta say it and they do have
it they have the best time man I gotta
say you guys I mean straight you guys
are out there pump your dicks out and
just let I'm sorry people have boring
sexy you're right by the sound of it
you're absolutely not right you know
because straight people just don't I
don't know it's like they're just boring
sex I mean you know I always have
straight guys telling my God I I can't
believe you gay guys have so much fun
because don't forget too you can't do a
lot with a woman because women first of
all their buys are different and not
only that is what I have this with a
straight guy on me one day because women
will accuse of rape for everything that
most every straight guy should become
gay because they can never have sex with
a woman because women don't want sex and
I don't know how true that is but that's
true exactly I mean but you know a lot
of guys are telling me this they're like
oh you know I'm really jealous because
you gay you guys like to have fun we
were men why should we be afraid we're
we're you know Mass we want to have fun
we're not scared to have fun with other
dudes well there it is
out there living his best well I have in
a while I've been [__] he's dead in
leaving loads I've been getting
loads of bath houses
I have another shoot plan in July for my
wrestling shoot and that's gonna be
really big because I actually got some
really good people that want to come and
wrestle nude or shorts at the foot
worship person who's the worst of
women's feet in St Petersburg Florida
and I'm trying to do a shoot out in L.A
well actually What's it gonna do
California but there was two guys I'd
met who were interfere but want to do a
little bit more so I'm trying to find a
one day venue I can rent it's hard to
rent spaces for one day but departments
in LA and then someone told me I should
do San Jose and they've been to San Jose
this guy told me definitely go San Jose
because it's this emerging market and
LA's difficult to compete what do you
think about letting c-man use our studio
space for a day isn't it it's on a
Saturday you said I mean
every day of the week so I'm not sure
where what on a weekend I mean you you
clean up right there's no semen left on
the floor no there would be it would
just be foot licking and then a lot of
fun looking Dan I mean it's yours you
can do whatever you want yeah you might
be able to use our our space I think
that could be fun and interesting
chair
and then but you know but you guys know
someone from our team's got to be there
to report on it maybe info bread that'd
be a good on the field report for you I
mean even says great like man on the
streets I'm also trying to do event in
Philadelphia
because I think it ties great with my
you know city of broadly love which is
great with Philadelphia and I know that
it's a big scene down there just I'm
trying to get you know some of the
places you can rent for a day but some
sports see man when you're coming out to
LA let us know we can work out something
where you can use our studio and one of
our guys will just do like a report on
it like I think I think Ian or we're
gonna be naked none of that is gonna
happen see man he's wait what he's
kidding no I'm not okay oh well
it's all right who's kidding I mean I'll
keep pants I don't care I mean but I
know I have I actually had another
really
um
sorry to tell you I do have to go uh we
have my my wife ela's on the other line
uh she has some news first what happened
I've been I haven't really followed up
too much what's going to you guys not
together or you still are or been on the
show together or what what's going on no
she's just not here today in fact oh
because I was reading on some of the
shows that I guess that she was not on
every show with you but I guess that's
fine uh
no uh despite what fresh and fit thinks
we are still together or click bait
titles yeah but uh no we're still
together she she's busy yeah she's just
busy she she doesn't do the class with
us as much anymore but listen see man
I'm gonna let you go but I'm so glad we
got to connect let's stay in touch if
you're coming out to LA I'm serious
let's let's uh let's we'll figure
something out okay that'd be nice I
appreciate it I'm sorry about the whole
driving thing but no no no no you're
good you're good you know I work out
Long Island in Garden City and I take
the Meadowbrook to the grandson you're
good don't don't worry about it all
right be good okay
and clean that clean to come I know you
would but I'm just saying make don't
leave that comment that could be a great
marketing thing that sounds really good
that could be a really good all right
thank you see you man take care we'll
talk to you soon
[Music]
and that is uh everybody's favorite sea
man from New York Brooklyn I'm sorry
then you do not think that's a good idea
you should not volunteer your uh
employees for uh doing well I'm not
gonna send someone on will who doesn't
want to do it I mean what do you think
I'm not gonna make someone do it
you get lost in the moment a lot when
we're talking to guests and uh I'm not
proposing anyone to do the segment Dan
okay
sure we can find someone who's down to
do it I'm potentially interested to take
off we could get prostate exams during
that too
[Laughter]
well that's a I like that crossover
potentially
uh but uh actually info bran would be
next [__] level or uh who who else
was the man on the street we wanted to
get Jimmy Lee Jimmy
whoa I mean that's what I'm saying dude
it's good stuff there's potential here
but c-man he's a
he's an interesting guy man I'm just
glad we got to uh talk to him but he was
ready to call in actually she sent us a
picture
apparently
I guess this means she's pregnant but
we'll know for sure next week
but there's a thing inside of it
and there it is
uh Ela is connecting Dan
can't wait to hear the Freshman fit take
oh [__] we're having dueling podcasts
now
Candace Owen and H3 are wrong on the
Steven Crowder's divorce so I was
peeking in the uh pre-chat and uh some
of them were like really going hard on
fresh and fit some of their audience was
not happy and they changed the title to
just why Candice Owens is wrong they
took me out they took you out of the
title yeah wait why we're wrong why was
there Audi why did some people were
saying that Crowder's [__] up like
there's no defending him so I wonder why
okay but then he kept Candace Owens and
that's interesting but I love to see
that that there there's not a consensus
among them you cannot defend him without
catching bullets
you know
hello
hi
oh so here's the the one that where they
updated it why she's wrong and they took
my name out oh that's interesting what
cowards hey you look beautiful and
there's Lena who's driving you look
because she had to take off fat Valium
before she went in for the
how are you feeling Gala did you feel
that Valium
like okay let me lean back okay you know
it's like
you just feel kind of like comfortable
it's a the body is relaxed and are you
still under the effect of some kind of
you seemed like a little bit under the
effect potentially of something
and so how did it go
it went super fast
um and super well they sent they said it
was fast and sometimes it could take
longer for some people I don't know why
and um it was cool they showed me like I
sent pictures to you guys and and what's
up I saw it yeah they showed me I showed
it they showed me a picture of the
embryo itself
so that's what the other one
oh there's another one not
oh here oh crazy this looks crazy
yeah I've got it right here
that's our baby
put back in
and then in the auto picture if you go
back to that that's an aa4 embryo if
I've ever seen one
um
she's beautiful I can already tell she's
so pretty she's a perfect princess
[Music]
so here's the other one is this the one
because it looks the same but then
then the other one that you just had
opened before oh oh the this one yeah
the dark one with the arrow
yeah yeah so that that they showed me
live like
when they put it back in and so that one
little dot the white dot that's that
and so what's our timeline looking like
so we're gonna know on Friday if it
worked or
um or before that yeah from no not
before from what I understand next
Friday would be the pregnancy test and
they said that like home pregnancy tests
are not accurate so they do have blood
one
wow
crazy
is it it's too late to turn back now
uh yeah I think so and
um Ela I don't know if you knew this but
according to fresh and fit we are close
to divorcing because you're exercising
have you seen that
well I now they told me I shouldn't
exercise for a little while they said at
least until you hear a heartbeat okay
marriage said there it is yeah you're
saying
marriage saved we're back baby
now Ela
I have to ask you just because I I need
to ask are you exercising so that you
can return to the uh the sexual
Marketplace
okay there it is honestly I I haven't
watched their video yet
there it is Ela says no
no I haven't watched their
exercising was because after the second
pregnancy my stomach like and listen I
know people don't want to hear me talk
about it because I'm I'm thin I get it
but my stomach was kind of like wobbly
and it's kind of like jello and so I
wasn't super comfortable with that and I
just I wanted to feel like
I wanted to tone my body I wanted it to
be like
I don't know right
my own personal Journey from
them yeah they they can't conceive that
uh unfortunately
because they'll never have kids or a
wife or a relationship at all really
yeah well um but also it started from me
having back pain there's so many reasons
and ever since I started exercising I
just
but yeah the last thing I'm thinking
about is male attention when I'm
exercising
I don't know if I can trust her opinion
on this I heard fresh and fit give a
difference a balding middle-aged single
man said otherwise so he's a
professional on the topic of women hey
Eva what's for dinner what are we gonna
eat
um yeah I think we should celebrate oh
yeah let's celebrate
with not with drinks
I can't drink alcohol anymore and uh the
worst part about it is only one coffee a
day now oh that's killer that that is
killer
so what are you feeling probably Italian
that's what ELO always wants Italian
food
no I'm
okay
well I'm very excited I mean my
Third flying baby that is just that's a
lot of babies
now Ela would you change the topic a
little bit would you be opposed if I
invited c-man to use our studio space on
the weekend to shoot a gay pornography
film
hope you say no because he already did
I saw it
I saw that you said you would ask me if
you asked him if he would clean up
he said yes of course he would see man
would never leave it's not like Seaman
would ever [__] all over a public tiny
bathroom on an airplane I mean he
cleaned it up
we might need to create like a Dexter
kind of like Dexter yeah we can put like
that's hot tarp down that's right they
can role play as Dexter
but I like the idea of having like info
Bran or someone flying down to film I
mean come on that's [__] iconic
it's not porn people are correcting me
it's not porn it's just feet worship
okay
yeah
ejaculate
[Music]
so we can negotiate on that probably
although it doesn't sound like he has
much control he told us that yeah he
[__] in his pants in a grocery store
just by looking at someone's feet yeah
so
okay
just an opportunity I thought it may be
an opportunity for us to expand
I don't know
all right so uh well congratulations I'm
very very excited and uh next Friday
we'll know
I just thought your future child is
probably gonna want to know the first
time they were mentioned on the show and
to watch this and you can see that
transition right there that's special
well
that's what they're born in
Siemens sea man is pretty wild like
going in that tiny bathroom and like I
know he wiped it up but knowing there
was like jizz all over the countertop is
so gnarly to me I think you could pretty
much assume that in most public
bathrooms just jizz everywhere not not
c-man specifically yeah yes in general
maybe he does get around he's dead all
over the country yeah he changed the way
that I'm going to live my normal life
after that I'm afraid to wear sandals
without socks now holy [__] right I feel
like Ethan and most
he needs to wash his hands all the time
it's funny everybody will be like yo is
that calm we don't know is that a coffee
or is it a [__] stain see man did you
come on Dan's desk
it'll be like a whole Adventure every
every time we find a stain
there it is okay you guys drive safe and
uh I'll see you soon all right
and thank you Lena for taking good care
of her
all right love you see you see you soon
at home there have a good weekend
everybody good weekend everybody thank
you
bye bye bye so there it is uh
I mean what an episode all over the
place really all over the place truly
truly it's like Siemens jizz all around
here all over the place
I think I have a way to resolve this and
tie it all together if we can just get
Crowder and Seaman together we might
create an alternate universe where
Crowder has less anger issues coming out
of the closet and then maybe he can
reconcile even with his uh baby mama and
kids I don't know if we want to give
c-man
well he's Seaman is way better than
Crowder yeah frankly based off of what
c-man was telling us I I think I don't
think he'd be into it at all because
Crowder is totally like in denial and it
seemed like c-man he he hates you know
people who claim they're straight but
want to have sex with men so I thought
that was nice to be honest uh I didn't
expect it but I thought it was nice
you know I thought so too and his
stories are just always so special
because like he goes yeah we didn't do
much I come down the steering wheel made
him lick it off
I was like whoa
but that's just because he's Italian
that's just Italian yeah it's a little
Italian dressing spaghetti stuff come on
apparently stacked as well so yeah I
don't think we knew he had like such a
juicer I know he he kept him buying it
but ten
ten that's like crazy dude that that's
crazy that's like it that's like
even in in porn they don't have dicks
that big I feel like 10 10 or how much
for how much like video porn content he
says he records I feel like we should
have seen it by now but he's not doing
yeah that's what I'm saying he's not
he's not he needs to go more mainstream
if he's got a dick like that I wanted
you to ask him uh if he's considered
making an only fans I feel like with the
dick like that he'd clean up yeah and
has like the specific fetish thing you
know
that's true we gotta tell him I feel
like I could make a killing yo you're
right he would he would he would
big dick c-man right it could be his
account name
I'll be his manager 10 you could use my
office
get me a ruler let's see how I want to
see what's 10 inches
I want to you know
celebrate Seaman here as a
you can also get a Steve Rossi to manage
him as well Steve Rossi is looking for
new clients I love that he said it was
between nine and eleven I mean and 12.
so it was like okay so 10 or 11. right
that's a huge swing though that man
varies like three inches it's a 12
incher
good for him
he's a gay icon
yes so do we have time for the Sydney
Sweeney PowerPoint do you think Olivia
or I mean it's already over three we're
at oh we are we could do a Monday we're
at 3 10. okay okay so we'll save that
for Monday we'll save it
also this Matthew McConaughey story is
freaking awesome too
uh maybe just okay
I do think we should wrap it up but
maybe just one little video of the math
like because if you watched any of it
yet I have yeah okay so Matthew
McConaughey is trying to become like a
guru and yeah now I don't get this
because he's Rich that's the weirdest
part of the whole thing uh I don't think
he needs to wait this has 2.5 million
views who's watching this [__] it's he's
I mean it's Matthew McConaughey
and he had an All-Star cast he had Tony
Robbins there and like a bunch of other
famous motivational speaker grifter type
people like that he's selling a course
uh The Art of Living which
is frankly so abstract like it doesn't
even mean it he's not even selling
anything buy some hotties could not like
I looked at the website I read all the
descriptions and I don't know what you
would be paying 400 for I really don't
well here's a little extra but preview
for Monday
um and it's time to get this party
started I'm so deeply excited to bring
it looks like what were we though The
Architects room and the Matrix what is
it who are these people
[Music]
and it's the man that's really
responsible for helping make an event of
this magnitude possible there's over two
million of you guys from 155 000
different countries and he's gonna share
the really cool backstory of how Matthew
McConaughey okay
so let's see here so this
this is 10 huh
that almost doesn't seem
how's that even possible
you're doubting him 10. oh he's Italian
I feel like Seaman does not lie men
don't exaggerate their penis size
I don't think he's lying frankly I don't
know he hasn't thought about anything
else so I don't know I mean he has a
massive penis yeah I believe in the
sauna it was 10 inches that day oh you
think the the
the heat and humidity in the air yeah he
said that day he was like really right
right yeah it's one of those days okay
well see man
[Laughter]
we have the studio space for you my
friend like this bringing his message to
all of you go ahead I just realized she
said 155 000 yeah I think you missed the
reason that I time stamped this
particular back it up just a few seconds
it just hit me 55 000 different
countries 155 000 different countries
yeah yo Matthew is on another level and
it's the man that's really responsible
for helping make an event that was the
only reason that Clips in there I would
suggest if we're gonna only watch it for
you to uh
his entrance his entrance is pretty
phenomenal okay okay yeah let's watch
that one that would be number B here I
see yeah B
oh great without further Ado it's a big
moment
I mean look at this scam City dude
that's awesome
I've been there
uh so by the way as you watch this scam
unfold a scheme more like it it's more a
scheme it's a he's trying to get people
to pay him monthly for no no it's a 400
package it's a four dude Ethan it's a
four thousand dollar value that's yeah
that's true when you put it that way
it's 98 off
he is worth according to the internet
160 million so this guy apparently needs
more listen what I will say
is I watched through a decent amount of
this looking for funny clips or whatever
I didn't see anything bad you know what
I mean like obviously this is a grift
and like but like it's General feel-good
motivational speaker stuff and there
wasn't any like he didn't say anything
that was like red flag or like that's
bad advice there I don't think he's a
exactly so it's like I don't think it's
why are you doing this it's more just
baffling that he's doing it at all
exactly you know but here he is on The
Bongo
[Applause]
there's no look there's no Audi yeah
it's just one dude hold on let me get I
actually want to get a look at them if I
can pause it when it shows his live
audience live in person audience
use the arrow left Arrow
there we go
there he is the crowd is going wild God
goes wild
they can't get enough
[Applause]
let's get this yes watch how he loves it
dude
[Applause]
crisis out dude
I'm I'm ponying up for him we're all in
[__] it I want to pay the full four
thousand
thank you Dean
there's nobody in that room Matthew I
saw it yeah yeah thank you a Dean thank
you everybody
you know
after publishing during the nights I was
I was bombarded with the request to go
deeper into the approach and reveal some
process
and that serendipitously is when Tony
and doing their business
hey McConaughey we love your book we
want to go deeper and get shredders up
to Shenanigans
hold on tread we're almost done even
more practical with it I said uh
yes
and here we are
yeah when I heard that I was like wait
is he does he know what he's even doing
like some dude was like hey let's just
start this multi-level marketing he's
like let's get some hotties going like
he doesn't even know what's happening
right now
just some Tai Lopez [__] kind of guy
in the background it's just got him
involved this doesn't seem to be a
money-making scheme although again the
the pitch online is so vague that I
can't say that definitively it seems
more like it's just purely a self-help
thing I don't I don't think that there's
like you're gonna I don't think it's a
multi-level marketing thing or whatever
yes whatever he saw this homie behind
the scenes it could be that might be
what's behind the paywall this is how
you fix your life I said uh
yes and here we are this is homie who's
don't trust this guy Matthew we want to
go deep here some process
and that serendipitously is when Tony is
being called Tony hey hey wait is he
talking about Tony
can you talk about Tony Robbins oh he's
getting he's getting ridden boy Tony
Robbins knows one thing how to [__]
take money from people
people love Tony Robbins but he's a
weirdo
y'all remember that video of his house
in like the Philippines and he has like
it was like
Tahiti he's got like full-time staff
that worships him and they just stay
there all this [__] remember they
were like he has them all line up and
applaud him yeah he like walks in and
stuff yeah that was weird Tony Robbins
is you know I mean he's good at making
money
I'm skeptical in my opinion and I know a
lot of people will disagree has someone
like Tony Robbins or anyone like this
ever really changed anyone's life I mean
like really has does that work like that
I just don't I don't know that it does
like you gotta live to feel a real
change
Tony Robbins being like get up in the
morning you need to get up in the
morning and you need to work you do the
best at your job
get some Howdy's going you know what I
mean it's like okay
here here's a screenshot of his Tahiti
staff worshiping him when he's there
once a year
I remember your commentary on this being
[__] hilarious it's so weird
he's a weirdo hey we love your book we
want to go deeper and get even more
practice Matthew why we really want to
go deeper
we can make a lot of money
go with it I said uh
yes and here we are
after eight months of creating this
project this one live right here right
now with you
we have all intentions of supplying what
you demand
why are they doing the fake audience
it's crazy
we saw there's one dude sitting there
Tony
your ability and desire to influence so
many people and such unanimously
positive ways is truly inspiring and and
the fact that you're out to do more than
just inspire
you know
you're actually here to transform over
the top thank you for giving me that
call I don't know what he's saying
you're gonna do more to transform
it's almost like people can just
interpret it however they want however
it feels meaningful to them
I like that so thank you Dean thank you
Tony
also Marie Trent Carissa and so many
other talented folks behind the scenes
all right for choosing to make the time
and do such specific and high-end work
that we finally get to share with you
today
why are they doing that
here's the biggie man
thank you
all of you
there's one two million of you
you get a choice
you ain't got to be here
to be doing whatever you do every other
Monday area about to cry the whole thing
he's yeah he's like the monologue of his
lifetime
not you're here
you made the time listen we'll get into
this on Monday
but I see Shredder he's getting ready to
he needs to go to the bathroom okay and
so I'm gonna call it here we've had a
fantastic uh week a great episode thank
you guys for all for being here
uh appreciate y'all it's been a really
fun time and I hope you guys will tune
in again next week and hopefully we'll
be checking some prostates
um selling some live tickets oh live
tickets go on sale next week
um should I give the the tentative uh
schedule sure do we go ahead and just
put that out there yeah so we're gonna
do a uh just like last time a pre-sale
for our members
um this is a much bigger venue so
um
there is a chance that non-members will
have a chance to get the ticket this
time last time it sold out to the
members pretty much immediately
um but if you really really want to go I
would recommend uh getting in on the
membership thing um
there is going to be a code that we send
out via our Discord and the community
tab to our members and you'll need that
code to be able to access it on the
pre-sale and then the following day will
go on General sale for everybody and uh
so that will be the pre-sale would be on
Thursday and the general sale will be on
Friday
yeah I I don't know what this means but
I think that's great I like it it's
Matthew McConaughey in The Matrix with
the audience of one it's all Seaman
love that but yeah I love you guys thank
you so much to all the members told the
audience you guys are the best I gotta
say it's been a great week but the
viewership's been awesome so I thank you
all for tuning in it's nice to see
and if this is your first time watching
the show feel free to hit that subscribe
button that's right
everybody subscribe the battle is
happening I'll have you guys know
we're we're falling off again we're
falling off we're down to plus 324. hey
baby steps is still progress and you can
join the fight hit that subscribe that's
a hard battle Man the War of the subs
I'm determined to win it for you
we're gonna get in the you think that
it's got to turn around we're gonna hit
the three Milli hit that subscribe
button guys
anyway guys thank you so much we'll see
on Monday have a fantastic weekend and
uh
let's get some howdies going on the
weekend for you all right
it's not oh play the Crowder Wonder
place out Zach the Crowder of this it's
not work for me
no that doesn't work either
that's
s tier sound bite all right guys
no that doesn't work either
[Music]